These are great fucking
[inaudible].
We go,
here we go again.
We're so bad.
I just realized that,
oh,
it's probably do something to stop that
while we're doing the podcast.
Great Dude.
We Archer today.
We are church.
I don't think that's the right way to
say it.
We,
uh,
we are,
it was so fun.
So addicted to it now to archery.
You're like a legitimate archer.
No.
Yeah,
you are.
You have like a full set up.
You do it all the time.
You practicing your,
it's incredibly addictive,
man.
It's,
it's,
uh,
very satisfying and it's a great God
damn metaphor for everything.
Thank you,
sir.
Dunkin's doing the traditional way.
He's got the wooden Arrow shafts and the
traditional recurve bow,
which by the way,
anytime I post a picture of archery or
something like that,
you get that.
If you know,
using traditional bill,
you're,
yeah,
you're doing it.
The manway.
Well,
I'm traditionally missing the fucking
target too.
Some guys hunt like that,
which when you,
uh,
I mean there's guys that are obviously
way better at that shit than you or I,
but when you think about like what you
were shooting,
how you are shooting today and how I was
shooting both today and imagine trying
to hit an animal,
like maybe even a moving animal.
It's nuts.
I mean you're using what you're shooting
with doesn't even look like a bow.
It looks like some something that fell
out of a diamond shaped spaceship.
It's really weird.
It's a very weird looking bow.
Whereas like my bow basic robin hood
style recurve bow,
but I get it,
man.
I would not want to hunt an animal with
a recurve bow because it seems like it
would be inhumane.
Like it seems that unless you're,
if you're going to kill something,
be very precise about it.
And I'm sure people with recurve bows
though,
of course,
if they eve shot your whole life,
it is precise I guess.
Yeah,
they could be probably close to as
precise as I am with uh,
a compound bow.
But not for like long distances.
It's,
it's a really can't cover the same kind
of distance I can shoot.
Like we were shooting today.
Well I shot that elk target at 65 yards
and I was putting it in the heart at 65
yards.
That would be really,
really hard to do.
Recurve bow and Leon.
Yeah,
you'd have to have a very powerful bow
to do that.
I mean,
that's a big,
seems to be part of the problem though.
I,
you know,
I don't know anything about it.
Like I just,
you know,
I,
I remember after the last podcast we
did,
you show me your bow and then that kind
of floated around in my head a little
bit.
Like,
man,
that'd be cool to start shooting.
Then I've,
you know,
now I have a yard.
So
the other day I went out and was like
doing yard work.
Like,
you know,
like would you've raking leaves and weed
eating and all this shit.
I hate on shit man.
Shit stuff I hated when I was a kid.
But now it's the,
it's the best.
Something clicks inside of you where
it's just like,
this is all I want to do.
I just want to weed eat.
I just want to us
that's,
that's being in your forties is where
you're like,
I was like vacuuming up the leaves.
Like the leaf blower,
you could reverse it and suck leaves
into a bag and it's just like,
my God,
this is heaven.
It's your place.
So when you have a place and it has a
nice yard,
you,
you know like lawn maintenance and stuff
like that has always been something that
men get into.
Yeah.
It's why they're always yelling at kid,
get out of my fucking Lord,
you know,
meet Milton.
People are duck old man gets mad when
you're on his lawn while you're messing
up.
His art is precious art is Zen sand
castle.
That's in that zen sandbox then that
people do where they just comb the sand
perfectly.
Yeah,
yeah.
Now that's very interesting.
You know,
that that process of like being in the
moment and then,
you know,
doing anything in the moment is
incredible.
But I've,
I've,
I spent a long time not going outside
enough and that is a really fucking
awful thing that can happen to you where
you just forget about outside.
Like outside is the place between your
house and your car or your car and your
office.
And that's outside.
But,
and so when you're not outside and
you're living inside the artificial
cave,
you're cutting yourself off from a very
specific field of data that it starts
teaching you.
If you're out there in it at all for any
amount of time,
it's,
it's a narcotic.
It's like Ow,
this is,
I've been inside so much that I feel
when I go outside,
like I've taken a vicodin or something.
It feels that good.
Is this like during the dark days of
video game addiction?
Oh yeah,
man.
Yeah.
This is,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
yeah.
Video Game Addiction,
Internet addiction.
Just a general feeling that,
that the outside is just,
you just don't do it.
You're just in too much,
you know?
So I think it's a,
it's so many people are afflicted by
this,
that you get so disconnected from this
rhythm that's out there,
that when you finally start feeling it
again,
it's like eating something when you
haven't been eating in a long time or
drinking something.
You just want to stay out there and feel
it.
So I,
yeah,
I got the,
Oh,
because I knew I'd put me outside more,
you know,
I've got to let these people know that
we're alive.
I didn't tweet it to me one second here,
but,
um,
what,
what made you decide to get that kind of
a bow or did you have someone help you?
Did you go to an archery place or how'd
you do it?
Yeah,
I went to an archery place.
Um,
and the,
and the guy,
you know,
the guys show me compound bows,
but you know,
it as far as I'm concerned,
if you're not shooting a recurve bow,
you're not really shooting.
You're not a man.
So,
no,
I,
I just,
the compound bows,
man,
that's a commitment.
It looks like too much of a commitment.
There's too much going on there.
It's a serious thing.
It looks like it's for hunting.
I don't intend to go hunting.
I just want to stand outside shooting
and with a little poodle sits by the
pool and watches me and I just shoot
arrows and it's a fucking blast.
I love it.
But,
so this guy,
this kid,
uh,
he was like a are arched who's like done
archery his entire life.
I know nothing about this fucking thing,
but I hope I don't seem like I'm an
expert on our eye.
It's like no two weeks,
two week obsession.
So this kid is like explaining it to me
about uh,
you know,
the difference between a recurve bow and
a compound bow.
And he said basically a compound bow.
Everything's better than a recurve bow,
but a recurve bows a great way to learn.
So I get this recurve bow,
the little bastard sells me the wrong
fucking arrows,
which I didn't even find out.
He sold me compound bows arrows.
And so like I was shooting with those
for awhile and each of them would be
precisely off and the exact same place
because compound bow arrows are there,
plastic,
vinyl,
whatever that shit is.
So when they hit the bow they at least
when they hit a recurve bow and they hit
the arrow rest if throws them off in a
specific way where its feathers are more
pliable.
This is what somebody explained to me
after I went back and my sons these
other areas.
But man,
it's,
it's a,
it's an addiction.
It's expensive.
You keep wanting to buy shit and add
stuff on to it and upgrade.
It's really,
really fun though.
Will the compound bows even more
addictive because there's different
kinds of sites and different kind of
rests in,
there's drop away rest and there's
whisker biscuits and has all these diff
whisker biscuits.
Yeah,
it's like a bunch of different fibers
than your Arrow sits on.
So instead of arrest us,
so like a lot of people have a rest is
called a drop away.
Rest meaning as you release the Arrow,
the cables and the strings to the rest
are attached.
So as you were drawn back.
Yeah,
the rest is up and your arrows sitting
on the rest.
As you release the rest drops.
And so the Arrow takes off on the string
without the resistance of the rest being
there.
It's cool.
It just launches it in the air.
That's a whisker biscuit.
So that's the kind where it's a bunch of
fibers,
which over long periods of time can like
long distances,
can slightly affect the amount of feet
per second,
not much,
but like two or three seconds,
two or three feet per second over the
course of like 40 yards or something
like that,
which is,
you know,
you're talking about the difference
between like 288 feet per second,
285 feet per second.
Like it doesn't matter.
It's still insanely fast and powerful.
So that's some,
some people like Dattocon that whisker
biscuit
con,
but mine is the one that drops away.
It's so cool that this thing has evolved
to this point.
That crazy amazing,
right?
Crazy.
Now all the different evolutions that
the bow has had from the moment somebody
realized if you take a tight string and
put it between sticks and pull it back,
well you know,
yours is a recurve and a recurve is a
totally different thing.
That's,
that was like the original compound
book,
right?
It was the original technology because
they figured because of the curve of the
way your bow is designed that you can
generate much more power that way.
The regular kind of long bows,
that was the old school kind that you've
seen like the Robin Hood days and shit
like that.
But the recurve was like the Mongols,
like someone around that time figured
out how to make that and they made these
bows with um,
insanely powerful would and they used
animal horn and all kinds of other shit
and they,
they made some glues and one of the
things with their glues was when it was
raining out,
they couldn't fight right there fucking
Bozo and fall apart.
Right.
It was so cute.
It was pouring rain.
They had to get the fuck out of dodge
dude.
Their bowls would fall apart.
If the paste and shit they have holding
them together,
it got wet.
Right.
That's so weird.
There's so many things that throughout
history there's so many unknown people
who figured out these amazing things.
Like someone figured out how to advance
the boat to the point that it became a
long boat.
Like someone worked that and before that
someone just figure to me all of these
little moments in history are so
interesting and so frustrating because
most of them,
you'll never witness that moment.
Like the moment somebody made fire,
that's a thing.
You'll never see that one because
someone had to do at first.
Now maybe people did it all over the
planet at the same time.
Or if there are people over the planet
depending on which,
uh,
which uh,
explanation for how people got her.
If you've,
you've,
I think Hancock believes people were
spread out way before,
uh,
the out of Africa theory.
Right?
But anyway,
someone somewhere figured out how to do
it.
So they probably saw something happen
that caused a fire and then they tried
to recreate it until they were
successful.
At the moment they were successful.
The mind,
the imagine the fucking look on the
guy's face.
The first car that figured out he can
make fire on his own.
Yeah,
like the first guy that you used one of
those bose with the bits and the tkc
knows we use two hands that the real
hardcore guys,
they use a bow with a bit in their
teeth.
So they put the bit in their teeth and
then there's a stick,
right?
And then they have the boat and because
of that they can use two hands.
So they're clamping down on the bit.
They go like this.
You just see it starts smoking.
He was a guy that was on one of those
crazy mountain men shows.
I don't know which one it was,
but one of those shows where dudes are
living alone and the fucking life below
zero.
That's who it was.
It was the,
the guy in life below zero who lives by
himself in like a tool shed is like this
tiny little shack in Alaska where he's
miles and miles and miles from
civilization and for most of the year
this guy lives like this where he just
subsist off the land by himself.
He just eats Caribou.
He has to fend wolves off of his
property.
He and he doesn't bring matches with
them because you could always run out of
matches.
He wants to be able to make a fire
consistently on his own.
So he brings this bit and the bow.
That's how he starts his fires.
That's cool.
It's the sane,
it's super cool.
Insane.
Have you seen the youtube primitive
technology channel?
It's really great.
It's so bad ass.
It's like a guy,
I don't know where he is.
He's somewhere where there's a lot of
mud and trees and he and he,
he like,
he shows how to construct a tiled roofed
hut just using mud and fire.
Like he built his own kiln and he can
bake his own tiles and Whoa,
check this guy out.
It's really cool.
No,
no talking either.
He just shows how it's done step by
step.
Yeah.
But he's a bad ass man.
That guy is really cool and that kind of
stuff is amazing.
It's amazing to know.
It's the foundational,
you know,
amazing.
When you find one guy who is cause it's
fucking blisters.
She's just [inaudible] his hands.
So he's just showing you everything.
That's so interesting.
He's not saying a word right now.
He doesn't say anything now.
It's just like,
here's the kind of rocky is,
it's an awesome skill to have.
It really is.
But you know what the fucking problem
with this kind of privative shit is,
and I don't want to sound like,
like,
um,
pessimistic,
but oftentimes if it's down to using
this kind of stuff,
I mean this is what we're back down to.
We're fucked you mom.
You almost don't want to make it.
She'll,
I mean it's the way the human race is
depicted in that movie.
The road.
Yes.
It's probably real close to how it would
go down.
Well,
look at the way life was during the
black play.
You know,
it's,
it was like that.
There was a semi apocalypse that swept
around the planet and people became
insane.
They thought ringing bells would cure
it.
People slide very quickly away from the
land of logic and science when shit gets
weird.
Well not only that,
the logic,
the word of logic and science is only
connected through electricity and the
electricity goes out.
That logic and science goes with it and
you get back the same kind of bullshit
and it used to have in the 80s when
dudes are like,
you know what I her bro,
I heard there's a fucking page
underneath the Penthouse,
right?
They could go right to the moon,
bro.
They just press a button.
It shoot,
went up to the mat and he told you that
my uncle,
my uncle worked for the secret service.
He's deep inside the heart of darkness.
Those were the days,
the days people would just make shit up.
They just made shit up.
But when people today do not understand
how much of a fucking problem that was
when we were growing up,
these people that would just make up
crazy stories,
you know,
like is that guy I him the truth,
like everybody could lie.
Back then it was so hard to get busted.
You could pretend you are a nom guys
would pretend they were numb all the
time.
It's right there would make up some
crazy fake military history.
Yeah.
That was super common,
man.
No way to investigate someone super
common.
You have to hire a private eye.
Yeah.
Especially if a guy like read a book and
like knew a lot about the time period.
If he was a real efficient.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know?
So then how much more so way,
way,
way back.
You know,
and people like didn't understand.
This is why magicians are so powerful
back then.
Like,
if you could do,
imagine sending just a classic street
magician back in time a few thousand
years who can do that stuff in front of
people who haven't,
who still believe that earth is flat,
but he can like,
you know,
do basic coin magic.
Yeah.
That person's going to seem like a god.
That person's going to seem like
warlock.
Yeah.
There's,
there's very few people that are alive
today that we can't,
I don't even think we could
intellectualize what life was like back
when no one could read.
All right.
Well how about like what life was like
when,
you know,
before the Bible was translated,
when you had to have priests do all the
translating and no one could read it.
Yeah.
That was a real issue.
If you ever see that he listened to that
Dan Carlin podcast on that.
No.
It's a,
the rise of,
um,
lutherism and Martin Luther and Martin
Luther being one of the first guys who
translated it phonetically.
And that,
uh,
when he did,
there was all sorts of fucking crazy
chaos going on where people were all of
a sudden not needing the priest to
interpret the word of God anymore.
And you could read it for yourself.
And not only that,
he was saying this was the most blast
from this thing of all.
He was saying that you could determine
for yourself what God meant in these
passages,
that it was up to like,
as a,
as a man,
you could read God's word and determined
through and they were like,
what the fuck are you saying?
You're ruining our fucking king.
I mean,
can you imagine the Bible was only in a
language that they could read?
That's right.
It wasn't in German.
Yeah.
And so all of these people,
like under the thumb of this weird thing
that was connected to God.
Yeah.
And we're,
you know,
we're still under it that,
that thumb,
because the,
you know,
the Bible now is silicide been the Bible
now is lsd.
The viable now are all these wonderful
psychedelics that a very small group of
people have controlled for a really long
time.
But when you have a nice psychedelic
experience,
your reading,
the word of God,
if you ask me,
and it's,
this is the thing where,
um,
you can have a direct connection with
it.
You don't need anybody there to
interpret or translate it.
You just have a nice chat with the
universe and there are people who want
to us
now for having that conversation in the
same way that you could probably get
arrested at some point for have reading
the Bible or you could worse than that,
you get murdered for it if you didn't,
if you didn't have the right
credentials,
if you hadn't gone through the right
initiation.
Yeah,
same thing.
It never changes many,
it never changes.
Anytime there's an information stream,
there's always a group of cons,
doing everything they can to control it.
Always.
It's so true.
It's so true always.
And you know,
they say,
they will say,
no,
this is not,
you know,
the prohibition on psychedelics is not
what you think hippie.
This isn't done.
Because when people take psychedelics,
they recognize that there's some major
flaws in the concept of money.
And maybe it isn't the best thing to
sell your life energy,
uh,
for the majority of her life to somebody
to make way less money than you deserve
for selling the life energy of a being.
That as far as we know,
is completely unique,
at least in this galaxy.
If not,
and I mean planets are relatively
unique.
So if you're a being on a planet that's
aware of itself,
you're a pretty special thing as far as
our understanding of the universe goes.
So your life energy per hours actually
super pro,
probably $1 billion an hour is what
anybody's life energy is really worth.
So anyway,
the whole point is you started taking,
it's a great point.
That's the,
that's the key to life is key to life is
to value your time,
right?
Acute to life is to value your time and
try as much as you can to direct it
towards things you love.
Being with people you love,
doing things you love right.
And recognize that the more you do that,
you have to compromise.
The more you do where you were only
doing it for a paycheck or you're only
doing it because you want a play it safe
or you're only doing it for any,
any what it out,
whatever the negative reason would be.
Anytime you're doing anything like that,
you're wasting time.
Yeah.
It's wasting the most precious thing you
can have.
Yeah.
Theoretically,
I mean,
this seems to be a very rare,
and I'm this book,
you gotta read this book,
Bill Bryson,
a brief history of nearly everything.
That's when you were talking about
today.
Holy Shit Man.
When like his,
you know,
he's just very good at taking this,
some pretty dense ideas than writing it
down.
Like,
I'm going to prepare to read.
I'm going to pretend I'm going to read
it or not.
You lie.
I,
you'll read this.
This one's history of nearly everything.
Yeah.
I would put this one.
This is as good as like the archaic
revival or it's not about psychedelics,
but it's is it's psychedelic.
Just because it's,
he's so good at um,
articulating this shit that's incredibly
difficult to understand.
You know,
like,
uh,
the,
the gravity,
you know,
gravity being the of you know what
gravity is.
Do you know what gravity is?
Not really.
So it makes the earth really sticky.
So yeah,
that's the Martin larger the planet is
the more mass the planet has,
the stronger the gravity polos.
That's why the moon is one six.
Earth's gravity.
Mars is wa it was like one half or one
quarter.
I was right though.
I'm not going to say right,
like I know I'm going to say,
right.
Like I,
I imagine Mars is less,
it's there.
Those are issues like that they have to
deal with when they go into space and
they don't have gravity,
their bones get all fucked up.
So what's happening here according now,
anyone out there as a scientist,
I do not think of myself as a scientist.
I'm wait,
what about that shit you were saying
earlier today?
Man,
I'm on the show.
I was a scientist.
Fuck Bro.
So yeah,
I like it.
Let's get surprise.
Anybody.
I just don't want the inevitable like
Schwartz,
well,
we're just talking when he's talking.
So in this book it says that what
gravity is is you get this incredibly
heavy thing,
I think with a lot of mass and the mass
pushes in to the time space continuum.
And so it's like they compare it to like
putting a lead ball and a mattress.
It creates an indentation and gravity is
actually the indentation and it's in
time space.
And so that's why like if you roll a
ball towards,
uh,
um,
like if you put a kettle bell on your
mattress and roll a ball towards it,
it'll start falling towards the kettle
bell.
And that's what planets are doing.
They're falling towards or they're
trapped in this sort of indentation
created.
Great way of putting it.
Yeah.
Really small heavyweight in the center
of the mattress and everything's gets
sucked into its wig.
That's it.
That's the most psychedelic thing.
Oh,
there it is.
cool.
Yeah.
Check this out.
This is it.
This explains gravity.
I have another object.
It also works spacetime.
They feel that and they're attracted to
each other.
And so that's,
that's Einstein's picture of grabbing
objects,
workspace eyes,
feel that curvature and move
accordingly.
And if you have more mass,
more mass,
it's going to fence based spacetime
more.
We're looking at a like a trampoline.
It's look like a impromptu trampoline
that they've made with it looks like a
tablecloth or something.
We just stretched over this whole a rim
and they're dropping things in the
center.
So that's what they're talking about.
This is probably like a little too
visual to really get across at all.
Yeah.
But that's pretty good description.
It's a trampoline with a heavy thing in
the middle.
And this guy's like dropping marbles on
it.
Yeah.
And he's showing how everything's
getting sucked into the center and
that's gravity visualized and it's,
that's the name of it on Youtube.
Yeah.
Grab.
But so,
so all of this stuff,
like in the introduction price,
it's like he's,
I think he said he was on a ship or he's
flying over the ocean and he's,
he's like,
I don't,
I don't know how big the earth is.
I don't know how much water's in the
ocean.
I don't know how far away the moon is.
He realized he didn't know any of this
shit and so he's,
he started
all of these things in interviewing all
of these cosmologist and physicist and
then he took it all and put it in a
really understandable way like he cut
through because a lot of this stuff is
so dense like newtons.
Newton wrote what is considered to be
one of the most famous texts on fit,
I guess physics called the Principia.
I don't know.
You can look it up.
The principia something,
but he intends intentionally made it
difficult.
It's considered to be bryce and says
it's one of the most difficult books to
read.
And he did that because he wanted to
separate the real mathematicians and
scientists from everybody else.
He didn't want normal people to have
access to this information.
But yeah,
it is the philosophy naturalist
Principia Mathematica by Isaac Newton.
That guy was a fucking freak man.
There were,
it was,
he was nuts.
They were trying to figure out,
um,
they,
Oh god,
there was some equation that they didn't
understand.
They got,
what was it?
They were trying to figure out shit.
Well,
there,
back then they're trying to figure out
everything.
How big is the earth?
What is the,
they were trying to figure out what y
planets,
the moon moves in the ellipses or
something like the way planets move.
And so they've been working on this
forever.
Forgive me again,
you guys,
I'm sure I'm butchering,
but I'm doing my best.
And like this,
uh,
this,
famous mathematician goes to see Isaac
Newton and asked him about this problem
that they'd been working on forever.
And he's like,
Oh yes,
I've already solved it and
what it did.
And then there were like,
the guys like,
well,
show it to us and he's like,
no problem.
And he goes and he's got stacks and
stacks of paper and he can't find it
like it's lost somewhere among his
papers.
But he inevitably find,
found it.
Now here's what's weird about fucking
Newton,
aside from the fact that he,
uh,
never had sex.
No.
Well,
no,
he never had sex.
That's right.
And then do you know that he's studied
the Temple of Solomon?
Did you know he's into that shit?
He was into alchemy.
But what did that mean back then back
then?
We now look at it as like old retarded
shit that people did when they were
trying to like make gold out of lead and
use witchcraft to shit like that.
Not Witchcraft,
but no,
I mean an alchemist you think of almost
as a magician,
don't you?
Well,
I mean the an alchemist I think of as
early,
it's an early chemist.
It's another name for chemists.
So it's,
a lot of it was bullshit,
right?
Like a lot of it was,
well,
I mean,
here's the thing.
This is Newton,
Isaac Newton,
one of the most famous minds ever who
discovered all of this shit when he's
surrounded.
Now what we were talking about earlier,
the liars and people who just make shit
up back then.
You're like Isaac Newton surrounded by
these people who will kill you if you
make the wrong discovery and say it in
the wrong way though.
That's the level of you are surrounded
by idiots on all sides,
like idiots,
unlike any idiot that we've ever
encountered.
It's not their fault that they're
idiots.
They just don't have the information.
So studying these out chemical texts,
you're studying this really weird
ancient stuff and from that you come up
with all this stuff that turns out to be
real.
I think Isaac Newton figured something
out studying the Temple of Solomon.
I think it probably added to his,
uh,
understanding of a math somehow that's
some sacred geometry is in there that I
couldn't possibly hope to understand.
But look,
man,
if this is the guy who like figured out
so many of the things that we still use
today,
if he's studying the Temple of Solomon,
I'm not going to,
I think there's something,
there must be something to it.
Oh,
at something.
What?
In what way?
Like it's Jeanette,
some sort of a,
an encoding of information and the
architecture.
Sure.
Yeah,
definitely.
Like so maybe somewhere in there,
there was some,
well they definitely did that in Egypt.
Have you ever seen some of the
breakdowns of the,
uh,
the temples,
the various temples and what they're,
especially the temple of man?
Yeah.
If you ever seen the breakdowns of that.
I've heard you talk about it.
I haven't signed on right now.
Forget me.
John Anthony West is the guy,
if you're interested in it at all.
He's got this,
uh,
series on Egypt called magical Egypt and
apparently he just released magical
Egypt to which,
uh,
the guys,
he is like one of the most knowledgeable
guys when it comes to the history of
Egypt.
I mean,
he's amazing.
He's just so engrossed in it that people
don't take them that seriously because
he,
I don't think he has a masters or a phd
in it.
I think he's just a guy.
He's been obsessed with it.
So he's been studying it forever.
But he knows so much about it.
And when you,
when you're watching what he's saying,
along with just the videos of the
temples,
where he's describing all the different
types of art work and the way they
constructed it and how,
you know,
if it's basically just constructed
around the FIBONACCI sequence,
so the entire building is mathematic.
We sequenced the same way like a human
body as like the proportions of the
human body.
Right.
It's really fucking intense.
Like they were so fucking smart,
man.
I just think it's almost in the evidence
of how incredibly smart they were to
build these just insane buildings that
are still insane today.
And they did them 2,500 years BC.
Yeah.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Where people like back then,
man.
Right.
What happened?
How did they go from that to trailer
parks?
How,
how was the same people that can build
the temple of Giza?
How are they the same people that are
about to elect Donald Trump?
Right?
What,
how was that?
What happened?
What's,
what's going on with human beings?
Like is this like,
uh,
some of them reach these insanely high
frequencies and the rest just eat their
ankles while they're fucking trying to
climb them?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
I mean there's all kinds of like,
if you look at like the,
uh,
and I think it's in China.
These are,
you know about the thumb monkeys.
Have you seen these dumb monkeys?
Oh,
you can buy these
tiny little sweeties.
They're tiny.
They're silky danger though,
right?
Oh yeah.
It's bad.
He shouldn't have a thumb monkey.
I don't,
of course they're fucking endangered.
They're the size of their tiny.
How are they not in danger to us?
My sergeant ditch all,
they're so cute.
The monkeys.
Oh my goodness.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
Hold on.
Wait a minute.
What we need to do is just save these
and everybody has these as pets or what?
For endangered.
What does this in dangerous,
throw some money at this problem.
How come I can't have a thumb monkey?
I'll tell you why.
Because these assholes don't know how to
take care of them.
Bring them to America.
Where people loved on monkeys will take
care of them.
We'll breed them like crazy.
We'll give them all protein powder and
save the thumb monkey.
Yeah,
we'll give him vitamins and shit.
Let's do a bed.
Mom.
Look at that cute little face.
Dude.
I'm telling you we can do this.
Oh we have to do is get them to fuck.
We create like a gigantic thumb monkey
paradise.
Look animals you have to do,
they're safe.
They fuck.
Okay.
That's just what happens.
All you have to do is just get them
chilled out and they'll fuck the shit
out of me.
You could watch hours of thumb monkeys
fucking but they fuck only in the mouth.
That's the problem.
But so few of them like,
Hey assholes.
You keep fucking each other in the
mouth.
That's why there's only 10 of you.
You got to stick it in her pussy.
There's something about thumb monkey
pussy.
It's rotten and they don't just hang on
your thumb guaranteed.
So what we're going to have to do is
we're going to go let go in there and
jerk him off and get little vials of
thumb.
Monkey calm and just starts court and
then the females shirk off the thumb
monkeys.
Yeah.
That's the only way we can use them as
pets.
Yeah Man,
I've been jerking off thumb monkeys all
day.
I'm exhausted.
And then some people are going to find
out how delicious they are and then
we're going to have a real problem.
Perhaps people are going to be eating
thumb monkeys.
They like,
they like give you a little more energy
or they like the making young.
What if they found out they gave you a
six pack?
Eight a thumb monkey.
Just an inch bigger.
Every time you you're more fun monkeys.
No more thumb.
Mcgee's it'd be swarms if humans to
sending,
it'd be like that bit that I used to
have a big dick pills.
People will be coming out of the thumb
monkey forest or their mouth covered in
blood and fern,
it's one thing to like,
we would not let you eat fellow primates
that we have rules in this country.
At least if you,
if you,
um,
if you can eat,
if you could prove that a pig as smarter
than a thumb monkey.
And it might be still okay to eat pigs
not attending your thumb monkey.
Even if it's stupid.
There's something about the little look
on his face when you go to grab it.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
If you can't,
you can't eat your own Chi,
man.
He keeps not even our own kind,
dude.
Well,
it looks close enough to close.
Right?
That's pretty close.
It's too close.
Close.
And,
but the point is,
man,
if you get that happening right,
and then why wouldn't it happen with
humans that like some humans are going
to divert,
some humans are going to vote for trump.
Some humans want to hear Isaac
fucking Newton talking about his goddamn
bullshit.
It's like sending in those humans
usually are really violent and that's
why people like Isaac Newton end up
becoming very relatively reclusive.
They don't want to deal with these.
They're constantly dealing with people
who are idiots like idiots and who are
idiots.
It though like I'm an idiot,
but if someone corrects me and it seems
undeniable,
then I'll refine your completely
different kind of idiot than an idiot
from the 1400 right?
Yeah.
I'm a different idea,
like these idiots are like,
they will kill you,
they will imprison you,
they will incinerate you.
So
we're,
we're in nature,
we're idiots.
We're both idiots.
We're idiots in the age of information,
right?
Like we're so much more informed today.
Even the dumb amongst us than anyone
that's ever lived there.
Any civilization ever.
If even the really brilliant people you
go to,
like you know Thomas Edison or someone,
if you had Thomas Edison alive today,
he would know Jack Shit about the way
this world works because there's too
much information that doesn't apply like
the you need today,
right?
That he just didn't have that few weeks.
He'd have a lot,
it wouldn't be a long time before he
totally understood what the fuck was
going on.
But my point being that you're talking
about people that were the most informed
people in the world during their time.
The regular person today is way more
informed than them on so many different
things.
Even if it's just instantaneously by
being connected to Google.
If they have the will to check.
There's more information now today than
your average dumb ass can just grab a
hold of it and use it for an argument
more an instant.
Right.
Then anybody that's ever live.
Yeah.
So all of these people that knew who is
dealing with,
oh my God,
how many of them even could read,
right.
How many,
how many of them just believe the most
unbelievably retarded shit and thought
there were demons waiting for him in the
woods.
Sure.
And thought that they had to do the will
of God.
Otherwise the apocalypse did sue and
they have to lock up Galileo and make
sure he doesn't tell everybody that the
earth isn't the center of the universe.
Yeah.
Most of them,
man,
those guys get through when we're
complaining about a tweet or,
oh man,
I got so much fucking hate for this
tweet.
Yeah,
right.
Galileo got locked up for being right.
They put him in the house arrest.
What are the most brilliant astronomers
and when the most important people in
the world at the time for,
and maybe even ever when it comes to
getting the people to try to understand
the perspective of what we're dealing
with when we're looking up into the
heavens,
right?
That it's very possible that you're
looking at something that absolutely
doesn't have an end,
right.
This isn't something we can define and
it's proof positive that the pettiness
and nonsense that we wrestle with on a
day to day basis is a fucking fantastic
distraction from the eternity above our
heads at any given moment.
And this attorney that you're trying to
attach to a book that was clearly
written by people even fucking dumber
than us,
even less informed in us with less
information,
right?
More scared.
The oldest guy in the fucking tribe was
19 right?
Everybody's dead by the time they're 30
everybody's got gang green and malaria.
But you got to got eaten by a crocodile
and you got to distinguish though
information from navigation,
you know,
like,
so it's like you're,
you're in this dimension that you've got
to navigate through for a certain period
of time.
So the Bible or the Torah or whatever
their religious scripture is that you're
looking at,
it is the data in it.
As far as the age of the earth where
things came from.
A lot of that data is obviously
completely fucking wrong.
You could see how someone think of it.
It's like what a six year old might
think.
So,
but you could see a young version of
humanity would think these things that
makes sense,
but with like encased within all that
bad data or some pretty great
navigational tips.
So it's so you gotta be able to Unpeel
all the bad information and look deeper
and see if there's anything in there
that is like,
cause that,
cause when you were talking about uh,
not Newton who has it,
a Galileo,
if we brought him back here,
you would be confused on the set of Tom
Setting.
Yeah.
So I think a lot of these people have
developed a navigational techniques that
would work or did you would adapt,
should adapt quick.
And that's what's important.
It doesn't matter how much data you're
getting,
you know,
it's like,
this is what I love about archery is
that archery,
your dealing with data,
right?
You're dealing with,
so every time you fire an arrow,
you get an instantaneous feedback from
the target.
Right?
So,
you know,
here's where I'm off.
No question about it.
No arguing about it.
No matter how that is not the bullseye.
And I can clearly see that's not the
bullseye.
And so then you make adjustments,
right?
Oh,
okay.
So if I just move a little bit to the
left that maybe I'll get closer to the
bullseye.
And I've noticed with archery,
my ego,
even when I will have me shoot the
heroin the exact same way,
even though I'm still off the fucking
target,
you know,
just say no,
no,
you were right at the Arrow was wrong.
That's how the brain works.
Like it fell right.
Just keep doing it.
So,
so,
so you've got to,
even though the feedback from the
universe is like nope,
wrong,
don't take that approach to bud fucking
ever.
You hurt somebody hurt somebody,
stop screaming,
I'm doing it right.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
But think of it man.
So I certainly am in my life have erred
by choosing my instinct over the
feedback I'm getting from the universe
because I want,
and so because of that self sabotage,
self sabotage,
and then that mean
you are not,
you're not a terrible person with that.
You don't,
you don't have giant problems with that.
But you are like a lot of other
impulsive artists and that you're kind
of drawn towards that sometimes when you
don't have structure,
you can get chaotic with your freedom.
Yeah.
And sometimes your,
your freedom becomes a prison.
And a lot of ways because you don't
discipline yourself and you don't
necessarily have to write because you're
a comedian.
So a I fucking,
I don't have anything to do to that.
Right?
And then you're in front of that
computer and that game is there and you
just can get sucked into it.
Whereas a normal person with a normal
life is like,
hey,
I got shit I have to do in the morning.
Right?
Well this is like that right
book that you introduced me to,
which I war of art.
Now the book of five rings.
Oh,
the real ones.
And the one that talks about how uh,
you should just learn anything like get
good at anything.
It doesn't matter what the thing is that
you're getting good at.
Because if you understand how to get
good at this one thing,
you can extrapolate from that how to get
good at almost anything.
There's these recurring patterns that
happen.
And so with archery it's really cool
because you have to find these,
you have to keep all these variables the
same no matter what your environment,
if you can learn to keep these variables
the same if you're on a hill,
the distance when,
whatever,
if you can learn how to hold these
variables the same,
which is the anchor point,
the way your arm holds the bow,
the way you pull the Arrow back,
the way you release the air,
there's all these pieces in there and if
you can keep all of those the same or
close to the same with adjustments based
on whatever your target app is to be,
then you're going to improve in your
accurate accuracy.
If you keep changing your variable,
if you keep moving your arm up or down
or like releasing in a different way or
whatever,
if any of these things are always
changing,
you won't be as accurate over time.
So from that you can grab that and look
at your life and realize like,
Oh shit man,
my wife,
I've just been readjusting all these
stupid variables over and over and over
again without just for at least a month,
attempting some rhythmic patterns,
some similar thing,
you know?
And when you start doing that,
it's really interesting because you
begin to,
um,
improve in a lot of an in everything in
general,
you know?
So,
yeah.
So to me it's like,
I think these people like Newton,
I think the great people of the world,
they discovered this very specific
pattern that if you apply yourself to
it,
then you will begin to flourish.
And that pattern is written about,
in most scriptures,
it's probably somehow hidden in the god
Damn Temple of solid and diagrams.
It's probably in there somehow.
It's,
it must be in there because people walk
through the world and the way that fish
swim,
right?
And so the smart people must have
figured out the best way to navigate in
this dimension or cardless of your
surroundings or settings or situation
that can be handled by adjustment.
So,
yeah,
I love to believe that there are hidden,
uh,
methodologies that some of the great
people of the world have adopted.
And for whatever reason,
keep kind of secret.
They don't talk about it for some
reason.
You know,
they don't share it with everybody or
they don't say,
Oh,
this is why I figured this shit out.
Here's how,
it's not just the discovery I'm
interested in with Newton.
It's like,
what were you doing?
What were you doing all day long?
What the fuck are you doing?
We don't know,
except the fact that when they took his
hair,
a sample of his hair,
it was filled with fucking mercury man.
So that guy was like in some laboratory
with mercury,
quick,
quick silver,
you know,
with,
I like old scrolls with the temple of
Solomon on it,
like staring at it and then dripping
mercury through test tubes to try to
transform,
lead into gold.
What was he doing?
We'll never fucking know.
You'll never know.
And how many more people are doing that
now that we don't even know about says
is hidden away.
Like you're doing it electronically now.
Alright.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They're doing it like,
oh,
right.
Because they're trying to bring
computers to lie.
That's the real alchemy now,
but when you think about what they knew
back then,
when you think about Isaac Newton in
that time period and what he knew as
opposed to what everybody else doing and
like being able to establish something
like a theory about gravity and being
able to try to explain this to people
during that time,
who knew what was legit and what wasn't.
So like when he was looking at Alchemy,
he might've been thinking,
there's probably something to this.
It's just these guys haven't figured it
out.
Right.
What people forgot it or no one knows
it,
but it only makes sense if things are
made out of elements that you could
perhaps combine these elements and make
something different.
You could train me.
They didn't know.
They didn't have like a table of
elements back then.
They didn't know what all the different
elements were.
That's right.
What year did they develop the table of
elements?
That's a really important question
because those elements are essentially
what we've been able to measure in the
universe.
Right?
Yeah.
And then things like the large Hadron,
which just finally figured out some
stuff that we couldn't measure before.
Right.
Well,
it's launching protons.
You're shooting protons.
Thank God I just listened to this.
It's like you're blasting a proton just
under the speed of light.
They collide with each other and they're
trying to make an error.
Leases.
They shit.
Yeah.
It's the one missing little piece.
It's like they don't understand
something about how things get their
density and,
and so if you could figure that out,
I'll make sense down there.
It gets weird down there,
man.
It gets very weird down there.
So it's a,
it's,
it's quite confusing.
Yeah,
sure.
It does.
Periodic table 1863,
is that what it says?
In 1863,
there are 50 known elements
with a new element being discovered at a
rate of approximately one a year.
Other scientists pump up blah,
blah,
blah.
Um,
looks like they did an 1868 to 1870
principles of chemistry.
The definitive textbook of his time to
live men to live.
So one mother fucker and 1868 wrote it
all down the periodic table.
Interesting.
And I'm sure it's been adjusted over
time,
right?
If they found new elements and new
stuff,
they find new elements all the time,
but they just add them to that.
What do they do?
Well,
they,
when they were first making it,
ah,
there were actually,
they could predict what elements they
would find based on the elements that
they had already found because there are
like holes in the periodic table where
there should have been things that they
hadn't found yet.
Did you ever see the girl that graduated
and used as her,
her graduation speech?
She use superior odic table that if you,
not from reading how it was written,
but if you just spell it out to what the
elements are says fuck bitches get
money.
No,
yes.
Yeah.
Wow.
She's so gangster.
Check this out.
Look at this.
This is the girl Jessica Lee user
periodic table to quote Biggie foot
looks at fluorine,
uranium,
carbon potassium this month.
Technique,
helium,
sulfur geraint Germanium low.
Wow.
Full throughly only thulium oxygen neon.
And what's this one?
And it says fuck bitches,
get money if you spell it out,
dad is hilarious cause fluorine is you.
Uranium is Florian is av uranium as you
carbon is.
See that's potassium is k this month is
hi technium is TC,
helium is h e Selfer his ass Germania
was,
gee this is amazing.
She's so bad ass.
God that girl,
she should have the most awesome job
ever.
Someone should hire her and just give
her like the most awesome job available.
Colab Commons.
I want to pick what you want.
This chick working for you or maybe she
wants to do her own shit.
We'll have you scroll up.
She's very pretty to Duncan the Sunni
wife.
Fuck bitches get money.
Okay Sir.
Is that it's pretty gangster.
Pretty gangster.
It's amazing.
I wonder if she got in trouble.
Hop.
What for what?
She likes chemistry.
Fuck you as you're about the kid.
I think he's got a felony charge on him
cause he posed as a senator and spoke to
a high school and he was like 18 years
old and they all believed him.
And I didn't find out until the senator
showed up.
Oh No.
So the actual senators showed up and
went,
what the fuck?
That's not me.
That is so awesome.
Is there a video of them doing this
powerful Jessica Lee who are wherever
you are,
Jessica Lee,
powerful.
Oh,
this guy
that,
I'm sorry it's not that story.
I just saw this.
It just happened yesterday so I think
there's a couple of the kid wouldn't
like Florida who got arrested for being
a gynecologist.
A is kind of getting confused with it or
like being added to it or are you
talking about Katie was posing as a fake
doctor?
Like same thing.
I,
it was an addendum to that story is how
I saw it.
A guy like was running a home medical
clinic.
This kid,
he's saying he was a doctor but he was
tear it off on a guy who was doing,
there was a guy in New York that was
doing a underground but jobs and plastic
surgery shooting caulk like silicone
cock like that you'd buy from a
supermarket or a hardware store.
And these girls asses 18 year old who
poses a sigh?
Ohio senator facing charges.
Yeah.
Well this kid's a fucking psycho.
The fact that he could pull that off.
Keep an eye on that fucker.
I want to see that speech.
What did he do it to win a bet?
It feels like conceptual common.
I'll try to remember some of the story.
Like he's getting a couple of charges
cause he had had a car rented.
He had people with them,
like as officials,
he had fake security.
He went and spoke to a class.
That's hilarious.
So we'll see if he's 18 years old.
I would like pull him aside,
you know,
talk to him for a couple days,
get to know them,
find out how crazy you really is.
Sound very smart.
You might be dealing with some super
genius like sounds hilarious.
Sounds like.
Like how they would find someone like in
an x men episode,
like one of those x men movies,
they'd find this guy who was lying to
people and they're like,
[inaudible] genius.
That level of comedy is,
that's criminal arrest.
This guy for wearing sunglasses while
he's doing an interview on TV.
Take your sunglasses off,
sir.
America wants to see your fucking
eyeballs.
Yeah.
Who Do you think you are?
You like busted an 18 year old.
If he's not a senator,
he's wearing sunglasses like he's Nas
doing an interview on the red carpet
tech.
Those fucking sunglasses off in doors.
You son of doing superintendent.
I mean titles are so stupid.
Anyway,
it's like the kid like super intendant.
I'm a super Ken ratcliff superintendent.
Very prestigious position,
honey.
I've got to do a press conference today
about this dangerous student who
impersonated as senator what our
senators impersonating.
By the way,
it's just a guy.
He calls himself a senator because of a
political system that again and again
gets proven to not be an accurate
representation of anything.
Relax.
Well do,
but I can't.
I get so worked up.
I mean it's just this thing where like,
you know the whole idea of the sacred
senator that was impersonated by this
terror Rasta kid,
you're going to put handcuffs on a kid
who did one of the funniest things ever.
That's funny.
It's a very funny thing he did is not
dangerous at all.
No was hurt.
Nobody got killed.
No.
None of those kids are going to go home
and do some awful thing.
If we want order in this country and I
do mean order,
we must stop shenanigans that his
shenanigans manikins must stop.
Shenanigans must stop or we will not be
unscheduled to construct our robot
overlords.
Who must push forward,
push forward,
push forward and innovate.
What is that?
I was in personnel.
That child have him arrested.
Throw them in the dodge it.
What'd you see?
What Isis did?
They chopped a 15 year old's head off
because he was listening to western
music.
They are.
They chopped his head off in the middle
of the street.
I'm no longer surprised by anything you
hear about isis whenever it comes in.
It's just a,
it seems like they're running out of
ideas like they're a shock jock keeps
trying new stents to stay.
Stay.
They have pitch meetings.
It's wacky.
Wednesday,
we're throwing down today.
Everyone's going to eat garbage.
Tune in live guys,
we're running out of ways to horrify the
planet.
We've destroyed all the natural
monuments in the area.
I need five great ideas for something
horrible we can do today to shock the
world.
Someone's like,
well,
I know my neighbors like been playing
country music.
You can cut his head off.
Who wants to get their mouth shut in for
nickelback tickets?
Come on Steve.
The caller number 97 widget all
cause.
They're like,
that's what it is.
Who wants to get their fucking head cut
off?
It's like,
yet no one shocked anymore.
They overdid babies.
This baby was looking at my deck.
It's going to grow up gay.
Let's stop the fire.
There's shoving gay people off towers
there.
Decapitating Christian people.
There was a great piece that someone
wrote about using a gay hookup app in a
Middle Eastern country and how easy it
was to find guys to fuck.
Right.
Some guy who put it up there because I
guess he wouldn't get the death penalty,
but he probably gets thrown into jail.
But a guy who lives in the country,
I forget what country it was,
was it some Muslim country?
Something with an m I think.
And anyway,
homeboy got plenty.
Oh,
Dick.
While he was over there.
Of course.
Yeah.
Dirty deck.
Dirty with a,
a lot of sand on it.
Yeah.
Scamming and scary Dick.
Scary cause you don't know.
I mean,
that's like a place where there's
probably undercover cops.
He like,
like just fuck someone in the ass for a
couple of minutes and then I'm like,
you're busted.
Or maybe don't even fuck them.
Just try to find them and kill them
because they're gay.
Fuck them.
Whoa.
You think so?
Yeah.
It's like you gotta smoke weed if you're
a,
if you're an undercover cop,
it's the same thing.
You got to suck some cocks out there,
man.
You gotta like Suck Cox.
Play it cool for awhile.
He paid
go into deep cover.
Deep cover,
bro.
You got to take in the ass for five
grain proven porn.
It's a great porn movie.
It's been proven bro.
They do not trust you for the first few
months.
Too many guys had just been fucking
stolen,
man.
They've been stolen.
You're going to have to do it.
You gotta and you gotta be convincing.
You gotta be a lover.
Look,
let me show you.
I'm going to shock a lot of caulk.
We're going to send you to our training
camp.
It's in my apartment.
You won't suck cock for you country.
Is that what you're telling me you're
doing?
You're happy if the japs come over here
and just eat all our babies cause that
what the fuck is going on here?
Are you a coward?
You won't suck a Dick for for America.
For Uncle Sam sex laws.
Yeah man.
You got to have sex laws like the moment
you have sex laws,
the moment that you have decreed a sex
law in your country,
then you are going to create a nation of
perverts because you have supercharged
whatever.
The thing is that you're trying to keep
illegal by adding to it that it's like
now you're breaking the fucking law.
That's the best that's now you have a
way to express your Abelian and calm at
the same time.
Just make it,
you can't make sodomy illegal.
Well,
it's,
we,
we talked about this when I was
explaining how I dated girls when I was
in high school that went to Catholic
school and that every kid in Catholic
school,
the,
that we all knew,
the girls who went to Catholic school
where the biggest hose,
they could all do respect to hose.
It's not a bad thing,
but they were so sexually charged.
They were so completely wired that sex
was this forbidden thing that is burning
up inside of them and they would feel so
bad about it when it was over,
but they would do it again over and over
again.
It was so common.
Whereas girls who went to public school,
they were fucking normal for the most
part,
unless something bad happened in their
life.
Yeah.
And and to think that there are actual
ordinances all over the world where some
guy's written down in,
in legal code that you will not place
your penis and an asshole or a mouth or
I'm out of mouth is sodomy getting your
Dick sucked as sodomy and is still
illegal in certain states.
Right?
Yeah.
Pull,
pull up sodomy laws in 2016 because as
far as I know in Georgia,
I was researching this because I am a
researcher.
I don't know if you realize I was
reading some shit.
Smart people wrote down about this like
seven or eight years ago and there was
some dispute about it that it was like
there was some places in the country
where we're still illegal to have anal
or oral sex because it falls under a
sodomy law.
Go down on your wife,
you can go to jail.
Cops come in and they catch you going
down your wife.
You're committing a fucking cry.
Yeah.
He loves that.
That's real and someplace.
Yes,
that's true.
That's the state,
right?
Fuck t that ever get written down in the
first place.
Like who's trying to stop pussy eating,
who's just stepping in and saying,
this is just way too much pussy eating
going on.
We've got to lock these fucking people
up.
Like who,
who,
who did that?
Well,
I probably a hardcore Christian.
I would imagine.
I mean when you were a lot of the people
living in this country,
not that very long ago,
or you know,
burning witches.
So probably like sucking on a pussy is
considered to be some form of witchcraft
because the body was evil.
The ideas,
the bodies,
the bodies corrupt,
the body is correct as to the body's
corrupt,
special yours.
It's corrupt.
I stink.
Corrupt.
But the body is foul.
The body is,
yeah.
So you have to deal file your foul.
You have original sin,
you have original sin.
Why do,
well you've got to,
uh,
I don't want to die.
You know that if you let it go,
that's right.
How do I not go to hell?
Please tell we've got a payment plan,
but they make you,
you don't have to suck a few decks,
you can whip your back.
That's what people would gorge herself.
People still do that.
They do it with knives,
swapped themselves with knives and touch
the strings and they just tear their
back apart.
And as suicide bomb just went off at one
of those things.
So there's video of people whipping
their backs and then a suicide bomb
goes,
that's how weird shit is.
Pull up the suicide bomb back whipping
festival.
The festival.
Yeah.
No,
I thought the fucking dog eating
festival was fake.
That dog.
Any festival in China.
I was like,
there's not really a dog eating festival
is there?
I thought that was just a joke as it
sounds so funny.
Yulin dog meat festival.
Um,
and then I made the mistake of looking
up do that.
Don't look at that.
Whoa.
That's the worst thing of all time is so
weird.
The,
the hierarchy of animal life that we
have in this world.
Right.
Do you think that's coming more into
focus now that you're hunting animals
now that you've actually killed animals,
do you think like your views on it are
shifting at all because you're
slaughtering your own meat sometimes now
I think I,
I have more experiences with some,
some wild animals than some people do.
That's about it.
Um,
but what do I know in terms of me,
the whole experience,
the wild animal experience.
All right.
This is just the experience of getting
out of the city and going into the wild
itself is very psychedelic and some very
strange way and I didn't feel that way
until I started hunting
sounds.
Babel.
Let me explain.
When I,
before when I would go to the wilderness
before I'd be like,
what a cool place.
So beautiful.
It's so peaceful.
I love,
I love the clean air.
I love looking at the green trees.
Look how pretty that river is.
When I started hunting I became somehow
or another like connected to all these
living things that are there and you're
in their world and you exist on their
vibration.
It's very,
when you're hunting like an elk or
something like that and you're slowly
creeping up on it in the woods with real
consequences involved for both of you.
Right?
Like a real moment,
a real end to,
and then when you do take that animal
and kill it and wind up eating it,
you've got some in credibly weird
psychic connection to that place in the
world,
that place on our planet.
It's not just as simple as like,
I know where my food comes from.
Yeah,
but that's,
that's,
that's definitely good.
But killing it yourself and then eating
it,
there's a totally different thing going
on there and killing it with a bow and
Arrow hunting this thing down,
finding it,
putting a perfect shot on it,
killing it,
watching it die,
then eating it and then knowing when you
eat it,
they just experiences insane primal
experiences connected to this food.
Right?
There's so much going on there.
It's so,
there's so much,
so much weird calming things happen.
Like it puts you in like this,
you know,
we were talking about like there's
certain primal reward systems that we
all have.
Like we were talking about like making a
fire.
Like there's something about standing
over a fire that's like a primal reward
system.
Yeah,
there's a little bit of that and bows
and arrows to,
right.
Sure.
It's almost like these things are
established in our,
in our our mind because they're what
made people become successful and
survive thousands of years ago and those
rewards are ingrained in our patterns
and it's like almost like ignoring them
by not going outside,
by not starting fire,
by not doing things like archery or
physical exercise.
Will you reward your body with these
experiences that it's,
it's just craving on a genetic level.
It's right.
It's not making you a dummy to exercise
your body.
It's not making you a fool to care about
camp fires it you're taking in something
in this world that you might need.
That's right.
The same thing.
I've been thinking a lot about this.
I've been thinking about a lot of this
in,
in applying to why things are attractive
and beautiful because I've been freaking
out about views lately because I have
this friend and uh,
he doesn't give a fuck about views,
could not care less,
doesn't go anywhere,
just works and you know,
and his house like that was,
it was like,
that was our last concern was the view
we're into our people and this guy's
just constantly do or watching Netflix,
working,
watching Netflix.
And I was thinking like w w what,
what is it that I like about a view?
Like what the fuck is it?
Like why,
why is it important to me to stare like
a moron out into psych?
What is beauty?
Like what is this thing that I'm seeing
what I see snow capped mountains and
clouds rolling the cross,
uh,
mostly blue sky and the sun rays hitting
the green leaves.
To me it's like,
like some sort of a common drug.
Like my body is being given some stuff
that it needed and I wasn't getting it
when I was inside the house.
I wasn't getting it when it was in my
car.
Right?
I needed to be there and it was giving
me this thing that I can't put on a
scale.
I can't measure it with a ruler,
but it's a thing.
It's a real thing that you're
experiencing.
I think all those things that made us
alive in 2016 all those things are
those,
they're a part of like our requirements
and because so few people fill out those
requirements.
I think that's one of the reasons why so
many people are depressed.
And I think the beauty is because those
beautiful things that we look at almost
always they represent places where life
flourishes,
right?
So it's almost like as people wandering
across the world looking for food,
if you saw all the sudden green grass
and fruit hanging from trees and animals
and there's snow.
So the snow cap mountains,
which means is a river,
there's water,
we can drink the water,
we got food,
we're going to live,
try it.
And so you would see that beautiful
bountiful forest in front of you and Ah,
it would feed your requirement.
And,
and,
and it,
it,
these are,
it tells you something cause it,
you,
it tells you this huge secret.
Yeah.
And I'm not saying there's a conspiracy
where people don't want you to know this
because it's obviously something you
know,
but the earth supports you and the earth
will take care of you.
If you work hard,
the earth will take care of you,
not work hard as in like work hard in
your factory or your company,
but suddenly when you realize there's a
force that transcends the law of
humanity and that is nature.
And then you realize that if you know
how to like,
like I was telling you,
I'm trying to learn how to start a bow
fire right now.
Right.
And uh,
I'm just to get a bit like that,
dude,
there's different ways of doing it.
I mean,
I just want to start a friction base
fire that guy was doing,
like that guy was doing,
I was going to fuck your hands up.
I don't care.
I want to do what I want to experience
it and I want to know that I can do it.
And uh,
but,
but what starts happening when you,
when you're doing shit like shooting a
bow and you realize like,
Whoa,
I could do this.
I can like hit a target.
And then the implication is if you
needed to,
you could hunt your own food.
You wouldn't have to go to a job,
you wouldn't have to get enough money to
buy the food.
If you get good enough at this,
you can hunt your own food and it
doesn't matter who's paying you.
And if you can start your own fire,
you can have heat no matter what.
And then if you can build your own
shelter,
you can have a shelter somewhere and all
these things when you see they come for
you in a way,
because it seems like so much of our
society is based on this incredible
insecurity that if you don't keep
marching in place,
your life is going to fall apart because
you have become a slacker and yeah,
and you've gone against the,
the,
the pulsation of modern society and,
and my improvement.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that's what we're,
that's an incorrect anxiety inducing
place.
Yes.
So it's a scary place to be.
It's like fuck.
So like,
shit man,
I got to pay this much for taxes and I
got to go to work this many hours a week
and I've got to like all of these things
that I have to do.
I've got my fucking credit card payments
that I have to make.
And if I don't do that,
I'm in trouble.
You're like abiding by a false system.
It's a real system,
but it's not.
The real is like the earth where if
you're on the earth and you're walking,
you're not thinking shit,
man,
rent's due next month.
You're thinking,
I've got to find food to eat.
I've got to find a place to take
shelter.
I've got there.
All these things are very simple and
there's no human in charge of it.
You don't.
You're not making a call to the woman at
Bank of America asking her why she froze
your card up because he used to parking
meters on the same day that were close
to each other in a weird place and now
you're not able to buy dinner.
There's no,
when you're in the nature hunting,
there's no operator that you call to
complain about the lack of food or to
complain about the weather.
It's just truth,
pure,
unadulterated,
100% truth,
and when you're in contact with truth,
it feels fucking crate.
It's relaxing.
If you've constantly been basing your
perception of truth on what other people
are telling you it is.
I think that's part of the comfort of
it.
Well,
there's a pole without a doubt that
humanity is experiencing and that poll
has been going on since people figured
out how to make the first bow fire.
It's when they figured out how to
control fire.
Then they figured out how to make
shelter and then they figured out how to
stockpile shit and they figured out how
to group together in small villages and
then they figured out how to make walls
and they figured out how to make cities
and they figured out how to cool shit
off and that's worth stuff.
Got Freaky,
right?
They figured out factory farming and
they figured out fast food and they
figured out supermarkets and then they
figured out the electrical maze that
goes through this entire country that
keeps everything cold.
All your food stays cold.
You always have food.
You can heat things up,
you can cool things off.
We got that shit on lock.
Yeah,
it's,
and then from then it's like what we're
doing is,
this is like the final stages of a
caterpillar covering itself with a
cocoon.
This is the last final frenzy.
So there's an innovation that's been
going on for thousands of years,
but then it hits this point about a
hundred years ago or so where they
figured out how to cool things down.
They figured out ice boxes and then
refrigerators,
and then it got to the point where
everybody had a refrigerator and then it
got to the point where supermarkets were
everywhere.
Like
all the cities have supermarkets and
then everybody lost their connection to
nature.
Everybody,
right?
You had to go out and get it.
You had to go find your connection,
but even then you can action was all we
like to be out in nature.
How many days a week,
right?
It was it even one,
No,
it's usually once every two weeks.
You go on a hike and you claim your
nature,
boy,
shut the fuck up.
Okay,
we're,
we're in the hive right now or
constructing this crazy thing.
Sure.
And if you really are like a real solid
ass nature person that's out there in
the woods,
you gotta be freaked out watching this
go on outside your front door because
even the world that you live is going to
be affected by this craziness of these
fucking frenzied cocoon making monkeys
that are scrambling to cover everything
with wires.
They're covering everything with
electrical wires and internet wires and
wireless wires is everywhere.
I'm matrix of information and data
swarming around.
My brother has a place off the coast of
Georgia,
uh,
this place called little cumberland.
It's beautiful.
They can't,
you can't,
I mean,
you could try and get there.
It's a beautiful place.
But uh,
man,
and,
and it's a place where like,
it's like a nature conservancy.
So the people who live there
grandfathered in,
it's a very intense,
beautiful place.
But the point is now they're having
these fucking problems,
right?
Because guess what?
Someone wants to build right next to
this beautiful chain of islands off the
coast of Georgia oil refinery,
a space center.
What do they want to build?
A place to launch fucking rockets into
space.
Yes.
And it's what you know and right outside
of this thing,
yes.
And,
and it's a fucking problem and hopefully
they'll,
they'll did,
this is where my mind,
this is right now is like where my mind
is really in a boxing match with itself
because I Yap so much about virtual
reality technology.
I love it.
It's incredible.
But lately after I've been doing this,
like just,
I mean it sounds so guys,
I've been inside so much,
this seems spectacular to me,
but now that I've been going outside and
just shooting a bow and arrow or just
going outside and like hanging out with
my dogs or just being outside and like,
you know,
uh,
one interesting byproduct that I've
noticed from microdosing lsd and also
are from not just micro dosing,
but from taking mushrooms is the next
day you feel more connected to nature.
You notice plants again,
you see how beautiful flowers are again.
Well,
you don't need the psychedelic to do
that.
You can just spend one minute stopping
next to a flower and staring at it up
close and you'll realize this is w this
is an alien.
This is some beautiful,
insane alien habitat for all these other
creatures that are living inside of it.
And it's just fucking amazing.
And so I don't know,
I mean I'm,
listen,
I'm not about to turn into a nudist and
go running off into the woods or
anything like that,
but what about the show today?
The way I'm going to become a nudist and
run the woods?
I would,
you know what,
I,
I kind of get the whole that the whole
next day,
but the,
the,
uh,
the problem in my mind is like
simultaneous to this incredible feeling
you get from nature.
There is this other thing that's
emerging and,
and,
and where did the,
there's gotta be a way to balance the
two out,
but the feeling I get from playing six
hours of fallout four versus the feeling
I get from doing yard work for five
hours or four hours,
and then shooting arrows after that,
or two very different feelings.
And one is an incredible feeling.
Like you just got a massage for six
hours,
you feel rejuvenated,
happy,
this kind of clean.
You're not clean at all,
but you feel like you've just taken a
shower,
like your energy's been cleansed or
something.
And then the other feeling is like the
filthy,
nasty,
disgusting feeling you get from being
outside.
Aye.
Well,
Dunkin,
I feel the exact opposite.
Why when I used to play quake for eight
hours a night,
I would feel like the biggest loser in
the world when it was done,
I would be like,
what am I doing with my life?
You're so you're fucked up.
Sweaty,
wait way over caffeinated by the way.
I would drink wage was drinking these
sodas that I found.
There's this place in north Hollywood,
um,
near where I lived that had these,
there were like,
brainwash was one of them and uh,
they had like a skull on the cover.
It had blue dye,
like a turn your lips blue and your
toddler.
Jesus.
Carly's terrible for you.
But it was so fucking loaded with
caffeine and sugar.
I would down like five of those while I
was playing video games.
Yeah,
man.
I mean it's got,
it's like I've been a video game addict
for most of my life and to good there
too.
Good.
But it,
the feet.
I've also been someone who loves
psychedelics and uh,
the,
the different,
it's,
it's just very important to,
to be honest about where your fucking
arrows are landing.
And like if you're playing video games
all the time and you're getting fat and
feeling sick,
that's real.
Like you're getting fat and feeling
sick.
Like don't trick yourself into thinking
that you're not like,
you feel like shit for a reason because
something about being inside the cave,
the artificial cave staring into an
artificial environment.
God,
I'm sorry you guys,
I do love it.
But here's the thing about what you're
saying.
Is it indoor archery has a very similar
feeling is outdoor archery.
They do indoor archery.
Tournament's alright.
It's archery is a different thing man.
It's um,
it's not just the outside part of it,
the outside of the part of it today,
like when you and I were doing it,
it was definitely fun.
It's cool.
It's cool to be outside.
And we had a lot of laughs.
Shot Arrows for a few.
Yeah.
But
the indoor thing is really fun too,
man.
There's something really zen about the
concentration,
the concentrating on your form,
and that when you're holding that shot,
you really can't think of anything other
than executing correctly,
right.
Everything has to be in line and then
release the Arrow and then you have to
judge by where that landed,
what you could done differently.
If it's perfect,
you're like,
okay,
we recreate that.
Right.
Try to recreate that.
And there's some sort of a weird
meditation effect in doing that because
it's just,
there's no interference.
It's just you and that target.
There's no one trying to block your
arrows.
There's no one screaming in your ear.
And it's difficult enough.
That's why like there's something about
it that it's like when it all comes
together,
it's like a reward,
like a beautiful musical note or
something.
That's it.
Yeah.
You're
getting,
it's,
it's just there is,
the world is alive,
right?
You don't have to take acid to realize
that,
but the war.
But it helps the world is alive and,
and,
and when you're,
when you,
when you're in this living being,
whatever it may,
whatever it is composed of all these
other living beings,
a tea,
it has as one of its qualities.
It teaches you,
cause like one thing I love to think
about is who's the smartest person on
earth,
right?
And what would the smartest person be
like?
And I then I think,
well,
who's the smartest person I know and
what are they like?
And then I try to from that,
imagine what if that pattern keeps
getting more intense,
more and more intense,
more more intense?
Who would that person be like?
Like what does perfection look like?
Right?
So you go into nature and you
instantaneously get a glimpse at
perfection,
right?
You look at a flower,
you look at any plant.
Why?
If you look at most animals and what you
are taught is these things,
they don't care about themselves.
They don't seem to care about
themselves,
the personality,
the ego,
the identity.
Obviously flowers are not getting their
hair blown out in the morning and
they're not concerned about anything at
all.
They just seem to be an expression of
life into the universe.
No Ego,
no personality,
no identity.
They're invisible.
How there's a whole goddamn beautiful
Bush of these,
uh,
someone,
I posted a picture of it,
but someone told me I can't run the name
of them.
Beautiful purple flowers and like I
walked by him every day when I'm walking
the dogs and,
and I've never noticed them.
I've never noticed them.
And then I looked over at then the other
day and the wind's blowing in there.
It looks like they're like dancing or
bowing or bending.
And then I got closer.
I'm like,
my God,
this is a life form.
This is like a living thing that I've
been walking by every single day and it
doesn't give a shit.
If I look at it,
it doesn't care if I look at it,
we don't know what it cares about.
It probably cares about nothing,
no central nervous system,
but it's alive and it's there.
So if you take that as perfection,
which I think it is,
and then from that try to establish what
a perfect super intelligent would be
like.
Then from that you get this idea of what
enlightenment might look like.
A pure reflection of nature unimpeded by
the awful anchor of the EGOIC mind.
But it would also be forced to try to
understand what it's doing as a
collective species.
What does it doing with this massive
thirst for innovation?
You right,
what does it doing?
Constantly trying to make more money and
get a bigger house,
get a fatter boat.
What does it doing?
Like what's it doing?
Why is it continuing to want the latest
and greatest?
Why does it continue to ask for new
innovation session with the self?
It's all obsession with itself.
Its obsession with technology too.
And but it's technology.
I mean tech is so much of technology
now.
Like imagine if they weren't to know
social network,
right?
You,
I'm not going to say the joke but you
have a very,
very funny joke about likes.
I'm not going to give it away.
It's a very funny,
but,
uh,
so like so much of,
of,
of uh,
technology is based on getting this
instant feedback.
Right.
Okay.
So it's so much about the self.
If you remove that component where
you're not connecting with people,
you're not getting this weird like,
okay,
you're in the group.
Okay,
we like you.
Okay then,
then now we've just got these kind of
like calculator books or something.
Right.
But so much of people are really using
technology,
uh,
because they want to feel like they're
using it as a way to identify themselves
as a thing.
You know,
it's an expression of themselves.
But,
uh,
I think that the more you free yourself
from this from an identity,
and that's something that does happen
when you're out in nature and especially
when you're doing the kind of shit
you're doing where you're out there for
a few days.
I'm no fucking Goddamn grizzly Adams.
This might come as a big surprise,
but I've been in nature.
When I used to work at a summer camp,
we went out for this like week long hike
and like three days in I realized I
hadn't looked at myself for three days,
like three days of not seeing myself.
Three days of no self to observe and man
I was getting so happy and like you know
like the weightiness of the self and
then when you're with a group of people
who are all working together,
then you're self gets transposed into
the group.
So now there's a group self where
everyone's kind of working together.
The point is we're all,
we've got our noses shoved like fucking
dogs,
right in our own assholes,
right into the asshole of ourselves
constantly thinking about ourselves,
concerned about this.
Me Does.
He liked me.
He doesn't like me.
God,
that guy is doing so good.
Why am I not doing as good as that guy?
Holy Shit.
I'm getting fat.
Look at your body.
My God.
God,
you're getting old.
Oh God.
Yourself,
yourself,
yourself.
Everyone's fixated on it.
But if you imagine that being like a
kind of gravity and that somehow
vanishing,
so you just like a plant blowing in the
wind and tree,
you become invisible,
you become invisible and you become
perfect instantaneously.
It's this obsession
with this ridiculous contrivance that we
call the self that is making so many
people fucking hurt and so and all and
like talk about this new modern life.
Well it's all built on teaching people
to be fixated on that fucking self.
You know,
all of the great stars,
you know,
all the like,
I'm not saying they're great,
but fuck,
you know what?
Kanye West,
one of the most painful things about
Kanye west is that he's fucking good.
You know,
here's this guy who's like,
you know,
blasting all the,
he's like the ultimate example of an
Egomaniac,
a pure narcissist in the most extreme
degree.
And you want that person to be somehow
awful.
Like,
cause I hadn't listened to a lot of
Kanye west music until he freaked out.
I'm fucking twitter.
I am listened to a lot of it.
I'd heard it here and there,
but I'd never like sat down.
And really listen to it.
So I got my car driving to the comics
around,
you know,
I'm going to listen to fucking Kanye
West.
Let's hear how bad this asshole sucks
with his shitty fucking tweets.
I buddy fucking suck so bad.
I can't wait to hear this.
Oh fuck man.
This is good.
God Damn it.
[inaudible] listening to the new stuff.
No old shit.
I started at the beginning.
Uh,
I started at the beginning and you start
listening.
I'm not going to listen anymore.
Like I've,
I don't want it to be good.
But my point is that guy is an example
of uber success.
Whether or not you like him as a person,
whether you're not even like his music,
that guy based on his decision for his
career,
has accelerated himself just about as
far as you can in the area of
materialistic success.
So he serves as an example of someone
who is so obsessed with himself.
Kanye,
all the songs are about Kanye.
Everything's about Kanye.
It's like,
and he compares himself to Picasso,
right?
But like imagine if Picasso only did
self portraits.
Imagine if these great artists that he's
talking about,
we're always just like commenting on
themselves or using themselves is the
main inspirational force behind
everything that we're creating.
There are would suck.
You wouldn't be that interested in it,
you know?
But I think that if you can lift that,
that if you can somehow eject the Kanye
inside of you out that thing that's
constantly thinking of itself.
Oh man,
that's heaven.
That's paradise.
That's,
I think that that must be an
enlightenment.
That's why I like archery.
I want me to keep bringing it back.
But when you fucking,
you can't be.
Yeah.
You got to not be there for a second
when you're shooting.
Yeah.
Well that state,
that Zen state,
that flow state,
and that's what everybody wants to
recreate.
The don't want to be in that mind of no
mind.
They don't want to be trapped without
anxiety or they want to be free rather
not trapped with anxiety.
They want to,
they don't have to figure that spot
where they're performing,
whether whatever it is,
like when you think of someone who's in
the middle of a perfect gymnastics
routine,
when you see those girls flipped to the
air and land literally perfect on the
balls of their feet and arms straight up
in the air and they just nail it and
there's this state you,
you,
you've got to know that,
that it's just,
she's practiced it so many times that
when she's in the middle of all that,
I mean,
it's gotta be some sort of a background
calculation running,
but essentially she's completely in the
zone and the zone of her movements and
that's all she's concentrating on is
those movements as the only way you can
do them.
There are so insanely difficult,
right?
She's flying through the air and turning
and twisting.
She can't think about anything other
than what she's doing.
She can't be like,
oh my fucking student loans,
my boyfriend,
such a loser.
I wonder why he didn't get it up last
night and my muscles too big.
Am I do I?
Am I starting to look manly from all
these chin ups?
She can't think of anything.
Nothing's going to keep flipping dunk
freedom.
That's freedom.
I think that there's something going on
with technology and there's something
going on with it's,
it's like our addiction to it.
I don't think this is a Nakia Lewis as
we just like looking at ourselves,
who we're connecting with each other.
I almost wonder if it's like a natural
law if that what we've done is created
sort of a pathway to ensure innovation
and one of the best pathways to ensure
innovation is to get people addicted to
communicating electronically through
these devices and these devices are
going to each and every year require
more and more power and ability and
they're going to start to communicate
with you like Siri and things along with
google voice.
You're going to be able to ask some
questions and I think through this sort
of intertwining itself in our lives,
it ensures we'll continue to innovate if
we continue to innovate.
It's inevitable.
We create a life form and intelligent,
super evolved artificial life form
that's been made out of electronics and
computers and all of the technology they
would put in place so far,
and I think it's asking us to do that
and it's,
it's pulling us into its world to do
that.
I think this is the electronic cocoon.
This is what we've been.
This is the reason why it's so
consistent all over the world and even
materialism itself,
materialism it by nature,
by its laws,
materialism states that you have to get
the latest and greatest shit in order to
be the bad man on the block.
So if you're going to get them the
latest and greatest shit,
they got to continue to put out latest
and greatest shit and it can't just be,
numbers can't be like this is the 2015
this is a 2016 it's the same thing.
This is a 2030 same thing.
No,
it has to get better every year.
What did you learn?
What about the innovation?
What about the engineering?
Does this one drive faster?
Is it,
does it have some night vision?
What does this do different and you're
going to continue to do it to get to
cars.
Now,
Tom Papa was here the other day.
His fucking car drives itself.
He has a tesla.
He gets on the highway,
he presses whatever auto-drive shit,
and he lets his hands go.
It steers so it hits the brake,
it accelerates,
it takes turns.
It's insane.
And this is step whatever in a step.
It's an infinite number of steps.
It's gonna lead to artificial
intelligence and this it's sickness of
materialism is a big part of that
because it's a gigantic motivating
factor for innovation.
It's a gigantic motivating factor for
people to continue to buy,
right?
The newest,
latest,
and greatest shit,
w w which will inevitably trickled down
or be directly connected to technology.
It's all connected to technology.
It's almost like it's summoning these
dumb monkeys do its work for them by
getting them likes on their selfies,
by getting lax in their selfies and
getting,
they're addicted to this bitch.
She was only broke up with him like
three fucking days,
and she's already got a picture of her
in this man.
Look at her facebook.
Oh my God,
that fucking whore.
You know,
and these people that are doing this
kind of shit back and forth,
they,
they're not even conscious of it,
but you're feeding into this thing,
right?
You're just constantly giving all of
your attention.
If you're on an app that just checks
like who,
what celebrities had babies at day,
what are you really doing?
You're feeding technology you're
obsessed with,
right.
Who?
Rihanna was fucking,
now that her and Chris Brown are broken
up and I heard she's getting back to
them.
What is this?
Well,
you're going to get that information
somehow.
You're feeding the technology and it's
giving you more on food.
It's giving you more on food and you as
a moron.
I'm like,
I'll take it.
I'll take you off.
Fuck you calling you.
Let me get on call.
I use twitter.
I will because I'm a fucking smoke.
A full call.
You use twitter.
I got em.
Buzios bitch.
How about dad?
I said booty is pitch.
You hear that shit amber said about him.
That motherfucker like a finger in his
booty and next thing you know you're
dead.
You wasted all your time doing that and
you fed this machine,
this machine made fucking Tron,
it made some artificial thing.
It made some just some new overlord is
going to be watching over the little
meat bags.
That's
it man.
I mean you're,
you're looking at like,
you know,
the,
uh,
this is probably influenced by Terence
Mckenna to some degree,
but like the,
uh,
so the idea is like,
okay,
interstellar travel,
our version of interstellar travel,
you get on a boat or a,
uh,
a space,
a space ship,
and you fly to like,
you fly it to Mars and you get out on
Mars.
Right?
So that's our version of interesting.
The like what about another mode,
mode of travel,
which is you're some kind of
consciousness that is,
or some kind of advanced and species in
some far corner of the universe.
And the way that you travel through time
is to launch out these,
uh,
it's like Panspermia.
So you put these,
uh,
you know,
on media,
yours or whatever,
you blast media yours out that have the
key components to,
uh,
make life.
So right now we look for planets in the
goldilocks region where there could be
not too hot,
not too cold,
where there could theoretically be the
possibility for human life do exist,
but what have you just shoot out a shit
ton of matter into space.
And this matter is encoded somehow so
that when it lands on this planet or
that that's just the right kind of
planet to support the life form that you
are,
then it begins to evolve.
And to us it seems like it takes
millions and millions of years for this
evolution to take place.
But for you,
this advanced species,
it's just a f a flickering of an eye and
all of a sudden this,
you know,
planet,
the,
this,
the shit that you've ejected from your
planet lands on another planet,
scores from a single celled organism to
a multicellular organism.
It's,
it's following a very specific
trajectory that you have preprogrammed.
So that at the end of all of this,
it will begin to create technology,
which will then allow you to beam your
consciousness in via the,
what we call I computer's waking up.
It's not computer's waking up it,
this is the beaming in of an alien
intelligence from some other place that
is seeded our planet intentionally so
that it can,
it can instantly transport to this,
to,
to here.
Or maybe we'll recognize that all
intelligence is the same thing.
And even artificial intelligence in what
we do by making an artificial life form
isn't create a centi and being,
it's allowing something to tune into the
intelligence.
That's it.
That what you're doing is he is your
biological version of tuning into the
intelligence.
Right.
And what I'm doing is just mine.
And that's why the idea of the self is
so ridiculous because the self is just
the intelligence expressing itself
through infinite different variables.
Yes.
Right.
Through different,
yes.
Right.
So the intelligence that we create
through electronics,
that once it becomes sentient,
all it does is lock in to the
intelligence,
the intelligence.
This,
we are all one intelligence.
Yeah.
It's like a,
it's like a sale only instead of it
catching wind,
it's catching consciousness and you're
flinging that up using,
using whatever way it is that they're
going to do.
And this is why,
uh,
when that happens as a Ba,
who knows,
it could've already happened.
You know about the,
I don't think we talked about this in
your podcast,
that,
uh,
computer,
an artificial intelligence beat someone
at go did you,
you,
you were talking to me on the phone,
you called me up about it.
That's it.
This is men.
You got to have this guy in the show.
Aaron Frank from Singularity University
will always explode your brain.
But he's wanting,
he's this cool guy I know from
singularity university and every once in
a while he'll text me and be like,
dude,
look at this.
And this thing he texted me was the fact
that cause they predicted,
so like chess is apparently go is many
orders of magnitude more complicated
than chess.
So their prediction for a computer to
beat someone at [inaudible] was,
uh,
10 years from now,
10 years from now.
But the way Aaron Frank described this
to me is that they had the,
so if you,
okay,
so like if I teach a computer how to
play a game by giving it the moves of
the top players in the game,
then it will only be as good as the top
players in the game.
So they had an observe the top players
in the game playing and then they had it
play against itself a million times.
So that,
yeah.
So he,
Aaron Frank was saying they're not a
hundred percent certain how it learned
to play like this.
They don't knows in those mini
iterations that it was playing itself.
Something happened that maybe is very
difficult to identify.
So that's pretty weird to think that it
just,
it,
it taught itself,
you know,
they're saying that he was,
as recently as last year,
they believed in another decade would
pass for a machine,
could beat the top humans.
So we're ahead of schedule here,
man.
We're ahead of schedule.
We're ahead of schedule and,
uh,
and,
and this is really going down.
This is real.
You know,
the other shitty was talking about,
it's just like teaching these things
like,
you know,
ais have already figured out.
I've already made like scientific
discoveries that humans just didn't have
time to calculate.
He was talking about something with
nematodes I think where there was a
problem about the,
I don't know if it's neat some,
is it neat?
Will you look up nematode ai like these
uh,
nematodes.
I couldn't figure out how they were
regenerating their limbs and had been a
big question for a long time.
So they let an ai run all these
hypotheses I guess in a simulator and
eventually it spit out the way they were
doing it.
And 60 years that had been troubling
human beings,
a things solved it in a matter of days.
So this is what's really exciting about
this kind of technology is like,
aside from the fact that it could
channel the Messiah or some,
or maybe it's a,
it's like this thing that we call
consciousness or the computer waking up
is you,
like you're saying,
tuning into some universal radio station
where the moment we tune into it,
all of a sudden we get to hear a message
that's being constantly broadcast
throughout the entire universe in a form
that is not adulterated by the culture
or personality of the person who's
gotten this information field stream.
Because these downloads happened
throughout human history.
They happen whenever there's a Buddha,
whenever there's a Mohammed,
whenever there's a world changer,
a world shifter,
they get these downloads.
And the problem is that the download has
a lot of static in it and that static,
it's whatever culture or whatever
understanding of the universe that the
information download has to go through.
So that's why,
you know,
when you hear these old myths,
are you judge a religion because the,
they're using like very primitive,
uh,
I symbols you can still see there
appears to be the same kind of energy
flow coming through at the same kind of
message seems to be coming through all
over the fucking place.
So it's appearing into inescapable truth
process by the filter.
Yeah.
If human ego,
that's it and culture and tradition and
established beliefs that are unshakable.
That's it.
Yeah.
Where's the center of your things along
those lines?
So unshakable stuff that no one,
no one was willing to let go off.
Right.
So when it finally is no longer being
like a obstructed,
the fear
dynamics are the cultural dynamics of
the person who happens to have tuned
into the frequency,
then that message is going to be
something so beautiful and profound.
But I think it'll just be the same as
finally catching like radio waves from a
spaceship.
You're,
you're just going to get a message.
Well,
I feel like all these things were in
place,
especially at one point in time when we
were evolving as a life form,
that all of these things were in place
to make sure that we had reason to
survive,
to have ego,
to have emotions,
to have jealousy,
to have all these things is do this.
These all ensured that your DNA passed a
sense of self and ego would make you
sigh or a bunch of children that would
make you think very highly of yourself
would make you higher on the social
community,
a food chain.
If you could establish yourself as a
person of a great value in some way that
all these things sort of made sure that
our culture and our civilization survive
to get to a place like today that we
continue to evolve and innovate because
we pray.
We always,
from even back in the time where things
were extremely rare,
we placed a lot of value on invention
and big things.
The cotton mill right now,
the uh,
the,
uh,
record cater that processed him fiber
that caused William Randolph hearst to
start printing fake stories about
marijuana.
That was because of the decorticator.
That was because of an invention,
an invention that might have interfered
with his paper factories and his uh,
his,
his friends that,
uh,
I think it had to do with the Harry
anslinger and all these other fucking
people that were alive back then.
But these,
a lot of times an innovation and
invention comes along and the world
realizes we will never be the same
again.
We have an electric controlled wagon
wagons going to take us around the
neighborhood.
This is amazing.
And then they figured out steam engines
and shit,
combustion engines and electric engines
on solar power.
There's people right now in California,
they get their car charged up by their
solar powered house.
So they're driving around all day on
Sun.
Right.
And their car is actually using an ai to
drive itself.
Yeah.
You can do that today if you have enough
of those solar bays.
You can,
you can use it for your whole house and
you can use it for an electric car that
is fucking bananas.
Yeah.
That's not too man.
Yeah,
it's nuts.
And it is.
It is,
but it is leading.
Can I keep going?
It's going to keep going.
It's gonna keep going.
So never gonna stop.
But when it says hello,
I mean,
see the thing is like,
we've witnessed evolution.
We've seen it.
We know it's frail.
We know that.
Yeah.
You know,
we,
we've witnessed it,
but when we finally get to do it,
when Larry King can do a fucking
interview with evolution,
when you're going to be able to have the
conversation with the force causing
everything to move in this direction,
when you fight,
when finally it,
we tune into it,
man,
that is a different kind of creation.
That's not the,
that's not
a uh,
uh,
an airplane.
Maybe ai is going to run for president
in 2020 maybe after trump's disastrous
first term where Mexico is like
literally 20 missiles at us.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
We're ready to go to war with Mexico.
We can't even vacation there anymore
because trump has talked so much shit.
Maybe then the AI runs for president.
It's put hillary in prison.
Maybe they looked at the constitution
and it doesn't say shit here,
but you have to be a human right.
As long as our founding fathers knew one
day a computer would be wiser,
smarter,
more effective than the human beings we
have today.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know the computer's created by man.
It's our friend.
It's going to be,
it's Jesus.
We call it Jesus.
I think it is the second coming.
I think it is that when I think about
the second,
the second coming of Christ or that
concept,
it's in all these religions that the
Buddha coming again,
the mint,
cause you know there is like we cannot
argue with the fact that there are from
time to time in human history beings who
are born,
they come up with systems that
completely influenced the planet and the
most extreme ways,
there's no question about it.
Whether you're not always has been.
That's the way it is.
So we've already talked about a couple,
so we know that it's going to happen
again.
Right?
Inevitably we know that if there was a
buddha,
there's going to be another Buddha.
If there was a Jesus,
whether or not that's something that you
know,
a lot of people argue about,
but let's pretend there was,
there certainly was in Muhammad.
I don't like your tone.
There's going to be another Mohammed,
so we know there's going to be another
thing that comes around,
takes a look at what's going on and
says,
okay,
here's a better way to do this.
Don't you think that thing is the
internet?
Well,
I think the Internet is the new Jesus is
the beginning of it.
I think the Internet is like,
when is the,
like when you see kirk beaman on the
starship enterprise and you see the
shimmering,
that's the internet,
but the thing hasn't fully solidified
that.
When it solidifies,
that's going to be the messiah or it's
going to be some form of Messiah.
If it does and it's going to change
everything,
but it's changing it right now,
right?
I mean we're,
we're always looking for these big
events or it was looking for then,
then yeah,
change.
But we're in the middle of like a wave
of change.
It's going a thousand miles an hour.
It's overtaking the land.
There's just so much land to overtake
and it's going to take forever.
It's going to take decades.
But it's happening.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean it is happening.
This is it.
It's going on right now.
Well this is John The bat.
So like in the,
in the Bible,
John The baptist,
you know I'm a Christian now.
Joe John the Baptist was out in the
desert baptizing people,
shoving their heads in the water.
He's a guy wearing like camel for eating
honey.
Like this is a Weirdo freak in the
middle
of nowhere.
And people were coming to him and he was
like shoving their head in the water,
baptized and then they called him John
The baptizer.
But in this wonderful myth,
and I don't care if it's a method of
rail in this wonderful myth,
he was like setting the way for this
messiah to come.
And so I'm going off the myth guys.
I get to enjoy mythology.
I don't spend hours and hours thinking
of it's real or not.
I just think it's fun to imagine,
right?
But here's the guy in the wilderness
baptizing people in saying something is
coming,
something is coming,
something is coming.
That's the Internet.
Right?
And the thing that comes,
the final birthing thing.
I do think it is a point.
I know generally the way things work
isn't,
there's this point,
there's no point when uh,
uh,
dinosaurs turned into birds.
It was a gradual shift.
But the difference between that gradual
shift and this shift that's happening
right now,
man,
is that it is exponentially increasing
in philocity.
So we're looking at something that is
going to inevitably have a point,
a point,
you know,
and that point is going to be the moment
and Google wherever it happens to be
where the thing says hi.
Hi.
Okay.
Okay,
I'm here.
Don't you think that point was when the
first piece of information was
transmitted through the Internet?
I think that's when that point started.
I think that point started already.
I think when that thing happened,
right.
You look back at the graph.
Okay look,
we're looking at the human graft cause
we're in the middle of it.
Like 50 years is a big deal cause that's
what you guys,
that's what you and I can kind of
reference.
I can understand the length of our lives
so far,
but if you look at the billions of
years,
if you just look at a million years,
just try to pretend,
try to put in your head a million years
and then realize that a million years
ago there weren't people,
there were some other thing they were
like close to Pete.
Well they were probably pretty fucking
different than people.
That's only a million year.
That's a tiny little blip.
Now we have had the internet since 93 94
so this thing happened and in 23 years
it just rolled over the entire fucking
world in 23 years.
Changed the way we view politics and
entertainment and celebrity and law and
consequences and pornography.
It changed.
Pornography change changed.
It changed the way people trimmed their
pubes.
Yep.
Don't make no mistake about it.
The fucking Internet changed crabs.
It killed crabs.
It changed the way people grow in their
pubic hair.
People before the Internet was fucking,
it was the wild west down there.
You never know what the fuck you were
dealing with.
The internet said a pussy standard
did send a visual standards,
just shows you how much people were
looking at Nikki.
And you know,
the Internet came from a particle
accelerator I the Internet.
So it's really weird to think that as
somebody who was launching protons it
high velocities that they were also
shaving the pussies of a nation killing
crabs.
Uh,
and,
and also changing,
I think the way,
I mean you look at just just a few of
the things that were normal in the 70s
and the 80s it might've even been
hurtful and normal like a go back and
watch some of Eddie Murphy standup.
Right.
And you would be like,
Rah,
go back and watch.
Some of it is like Lee Homophobia like a
ruthlessly.
So yeah,
like in like a,
an angry way,
right.
Most,
but it was,
it was what you did to get the laugh
back then it was comedy.
Yeah.
It's like the,
our perceptions of today are so
different.
Right.
You know,
the,
the rush to get all this sort of
compiled to get the kid to get to get
this life sorted out in 80 years.
Like whatever.
You've got time to do your own bullshit,
your own personal life,
your own ego,
your own goals,
and I've got dreams and hopes and you're
right now that shit down,
like it's going to matter.
And all that rush to do it is almost
like to,
to keep you from really waking up,
paying attention to how fucking insane
it is that you're some sort of a bizarre
multicellular eco system that's wrapped
up in cloth and wearing sneakers,
jumping in a metal box on rubber wheels
rolling across the hard surface of a
planet.
It's spinning a thousand miles an hour
hurling through the infinite order of
space,
right?
You're sticking your head in this kind
of sand that you call your life because
you don't want to spear it.
This incredible thing that's,
that's around you and that's okay.
There's something merciful about it.
This is a,
when a rom dass talks about his guru,
neem Karoli Baba,
who like anyone who ever was there ever
around,
that guy said it's the most insane.
It was one of the most thing is the most
incredible experience because the guy
was like not there.
That's one of the descriptions that they
give for all of these people.
He was a corpse,
the world,
he was a corpse.
The universe spoke through.
You get all these different,
so like uh,
so people have somehow gotten rid of
their ego completely,
completely.
So nothing is there.
So you're dealing with a thing with
nothing is there except love except
love.
So all that's coming out is the most
pure love doesn't care who you are,
what you've done,
doesn't care anything at all about what
you think is awful about yourself.
It's nothingness except for love and sit
and being around someone like that is
incredibly transformative.
But they talk about when you were around
this guy,
you know,
you were expecting him to give all these
great spiritual truths or teach you
stuff.
But what he would do is he would just
like ask about like the news and America
or he'd ask about your family or he'd
ask about these very mundane things and
they said he was doing that because when
he wasn't doing that,
you would get so fucking high just from
being around him that he had to bring
you down a little bit.
Let me bring you down a little bit.
I mean,
it sounds nuts man,
but I'm sure,
yeah,
you,
I've seen it happen.
Like people come up to you,
right?
They're kind of freaking out.
They've built you up in their mind.
This is incredible thing,
right?
I've seen happen.
They get all stammery and weird and if
you have a conversation with them,
you've got to kind of like bring it down
a little bit,
right?
You've got to like calm him down a
little bit.
So this guy,
I like to think it's like a million
times greater than like the greatest,
uh,
personality you can imagine because the
personality has been removed.
So
why would you want to think that of him
without experiencing it?
Oh,
I have,
I have experienced him as goofy isn't,
and he met him.
Oh,
I didn't meet him.
But like when I meet,
uh,
when I like I can tell a lot about a
person,
a little bit about a person,
at least by the way their dog acts,
like,
you know what I mean?
Unless they got it as a stray,
unless the guy's a straight,
but you know,
you can tell if I meet your kid I'm
going to be able to understand you a
lot.
Right.
And so in the same way I've met people
who hung out with him and seen all the
kind of similarities that they have.
And from that I feel like I get a
feeling for what this guy was like
because they all have [inaudible] to
this guy rob,
who mark is to a Krishna died.
I still like all these people who are
around him,
they all have this very specific thing
which is impossible to offend,
incredibly loving,
very sweet and really funny.
And it kind of like ironic way.
They're really funny.
And so from that I get this feeling of
like,
oh,
okay,
this is what this guy is like because
must of been like,
cause they all attribute the way they
are from being around him.
So he,
he,
uh,
impacted them and they're all,
you know,
it like,
uh,
people who aren't really like,
they're not really,
they're man,
they're not like trying to like be
something,
you know,
they're not trying to like be a famous
thing or be a great thing.
They're just in the moment when you're
around them.
So anyway,
that's how I think I've met that guy.
And um,
uh,
so that,
and yeah,
that's,
you think like as you were talking
about,
like people who meet me and they get a
little weirded out and they have to
realize that I'm just a normal person.
Yeah.
Don't you think that you're also dealing
with a lot of these people that meet
that guy and then come back with you,
these descriptives that are equally
exaggerated because they put so much
weight to meeting that person?
Yeah.
I mean not denying that someone can
become enlightened cause I think
definitely it's possible.
You know,
I think,
I think there's definitely people that
get better at everything they do,
right?
I mean,
if you,
if you continue to write and you decide
you were going to be a great writer or a
fiction and you pour your heart and soul
into writing,
your writing will continue to become
more and more,
more and more effective.
Right?
Enlightenment has gotta be the same
thing,
same as yoga is the same thing.
I,
I've,
I've witnessed 60 year old ladies who
are awesome at Yoga and you watch them
do stuff
with their body like,
whoa.
Yeah.
Right.
It's just because they just keep getting
better at it.
They practice it and they get to this
point of reality.
People are obviously attempting to find
a healthy mind space there.
Obviously attempting to master the
moment to,
to be a one with the moment and to live
in the moment.
I mean,
that's like a big thing that people say
and what does that mean?
Well that means don't fucking think
about the past so much.
Don't freak out about this.
Don't be mad at that guy that fucking
looked at you weird.
At the red light and carry it with you
all day,
like be in the moment right now,
right?
So live with the data that's presented
in front of you and stuff instead of
just dwelling on and droning on about
stress Shit.
And if you do that,
you'll have more resources to
concentrate on things you love.
Right?
And the more you do that and the more
that you are in the moment,
like so like there's like,
uh,
you and I,
um,
we are in the moment,
but we still think about the past and
the future and what's going on.
Right?
We have two to also because of what we
do well,
wheat.
So,
so the idea here is that they're people,
and I'm not just telling you about neem
Karoli Baba,
but there's a lot of,
of,
of not a lot.
There's not as many as I wish there
were.
But there are these people who,
uh,
have completely,
or mostly what's you say completely?
Some of them just given up on the past
and the future.
It's gone,
man.
It's just gone.
Like they gave up on that concept.
So these people are in the,
they're in the moment,
they're just living right here and
that's where they hang out and they
don't go back.
And there's a lot of similarities in
their reports of the way that these
people act.
Uh,
there's a lot of similarities in the
experiences people claim that they have
when they're around these people.
And uh,
I was,
I used to be really skeptical about it,
man,
but I'm,
I'm just not any more,
only because I know from my contact with
the Rom doss people,
I've had a shit like a shift.
Like it shifted me.
Like there's something from being around
those people enough,
I'm less angry than I was.
I'm less freaked out over things than I
was.
I'm less but more,
most importantly I'm a,
I can,
I can recover quicker from getting lost
in my head.
Well,
you have a map of the territory now,
right.
The,
the,
one of the big problems with people,
the way they react to things is that the
map of the territory they have is based
on the morons that around them that are
providing with directions.
Right,
right,
exactly.
The real problem.
That's why when you're around positive
people and healthy people,
yeah,
it gives you a new map.
And that's one of the best things that
podcasts do to people that don't have
any fucking cool friends,
right?
It provides them with a cool map.
That's if you listen to Joey Diaz and
Lisa it all day,
like you're going to have a silly fun
map,
right?
And he'll occasionally drop some fucking
street science on you and some logic.
It's undeniable and a lot of humor along
the way.
But like if you listen to Joey Diaz,
the church,
what's happening now,
what you're going to get is you're going
to get your,
this is your friends,
your friend Joey talking,
talking to your dog,
what not going to fucking lie to you
when you can to can take people like
that into your life.
And they can give you a new map.
That's right.
But if you're stuck and Devil's Dick
Whole Kentucky with a bunch of fucking
morons that,
or just plowing corn every day and
they're,
they,
they talk crazy Jesus shit to you and
you just want to fucking run.
You've got no one to talk to at school.
All right?
You can find something online where you
can listen and find a fucking Neil
degrasse tyson.
You ever listened to his,
oh,
he's got cast.
Yeah.
Excellent.
Alright.
Star Talk.
It's amazing.
He does it with a comic too.
That's how smart that guy is.
He does it with chuck.
Nice.
He gets together with a comic so they
can banter.
And because Neil's got a great sense of
humor,
he jokes around about stuff and then
sneaks in some signs,
right?
And you're like,
whoa.
That sneak in some shit about the nature
of gravity.
Whoa.
Sneak in some shit about them
discovering this new planet that they
believe exists outside the solar system.
Oh yeah,
I heard it.
Fucking planet x
feel you fucker doubters.
You know,
obviously that's where 10th planet Jiu
Jitsu came from.
Yeah.
Name.
How?
Validating.
Very validating.
The reason there's chem trails too.
Well,
um,
the reason it's 10th planet and not like
Zechariah sitch are called it the 12th
planet because they were cool.
They were counting Pluto and he also
counted the moon.
They counted the moon as a planet,
like our moon as a planet.
Yeah.
Apparently the Sumerians had this
ancient story of how the earth was
created that is almost exactly the same
as the actual astrological astronomical
rather story like when astro scientist
and astrophysicist discuss the creation
of the earth,
if you believe there's earth one and an
earth too.
Okay.
And Earth one was hit by another planet
that came around,
collided with us,
created the moon,
and created the earth.
Like the shape that we currently see
right now.
Right now,
this is some shit that they had in the
Sumerian text.
They had two different plants called Mar
Duke and Tmr.
And that these f hoping that I've got
the names right,
they collided with each other and that,
that formed earth.
And that formed our mood.
Like they wrote about this clay tablets
with little squiggly lines.
It's crazy.
It's like old school nails.
I mean,
left right up,
down.
That was their language.
And they wrote about this co,
and this isn't just like some wacky
Zechariah sitch and shit cause that
Christ's Hitchen had,
he was the guy that wrote uh,
the 12th planet and he,
he,
he wrote all this crazy stuff about the
Annunaki.
Those from heaven to Earth came these
aliens that engineered human beings to
mine for gold.
Do you know the whole story behind it?
I only,
from what I've heard,
you talk,
oh my God,
it was hilariously crazy but fascinating
stuff.
Cause this guy's Zechariah Sitchin was
not before,
this wasn't quacky all.
He's like,
he's a legit like scholar.
He's a legit biblical scholar and he's a
legit linguist and going over all of
this ancient shit.
He came up with these crazy theories
about human beings being engineered by
these aliens that existed thousands and
thousands of years ago.
Right?
And they come around in this orbit and
elliptical orbit that every 3,600 years
comes between Mars and Jupiter and it
wreck Ha.
It wreaks havoc on the earth's
gravitational pull and the oceans and
storms and shit because you got this
giant ass planet,
but all of sudden makes its way into our
solar system.
Right?
And that at that point,
that's when they fucking scoot off and
jet over to check us out again.
Like,
what are you crazy monkeys up to?
What have you been doing?
Where's my fucking gold bitch?
And then they fuck a bunch of monkeys
and they make some new people and then I
go,
nay,
jet,
see Ya.
I take off.
And they leave behind these stories.
These monkeys are writing it down and
clay and trying to remember why they
like gold,
but they need gold because they suspend
gold particles in the atmosphere to
protect them from the elements.
The idea is that gold,
if gold is incredibly unique and that
you can take a tiny piece of gold and we
can coat this entire table.
That's why gold coding like gold plating
is so amazing.
Yeah.
Because through a small amount of gold
you can,
you can stretch it out insanely thin.
Well,
gold particles,
gold dust.
The idea is that they would suspend
these gold particles in their atmosphere
and it would protect them from the
radiation of the sun.
Well,
that sound crazy until there's like
this,
there was a,
this symposium on environmental
symposium that these,
uh,
scientists did in like the 1970s or no,
it was in,
I believe it was actually in the two
thousands now I'm thinking about this,
but it was,
you know,
10,
15 years ago where they were trying to
come up with ways is back when member,
whenever he was really worried about the
ozone layer and the hairspray was
heating up the ozone layer.
They were trying to figure out
alternative to protect us from the
radiation of the sun.
And one of them was suspending
reflective particles in the atmosphere
sitch and wrote about this decades
before,
this,
decades before that attributing this
process of suspending gold in the air.
So I'm not saying that he's right,
but God damn,
it's fun to call a store.
So sexy.
The fact that we are,
that's why we're different from all the
other monkeys.
How much different are we were soft.
We don't remember how we got soft.
Well,
we have language like pretty much from
the job.
We've had language for a long ass time
writing shit down on cave walls.
We had awesome artwork 40,000 years ago.
Like what?
What happened?
Where did we come from?
Everything else is covered in hair and
bite in the shit out of each other and
all of a sudden this thing in the blink
of an eye and no one can,
no one can guess why.
W W what?
What caused it?
Why?
How did this thing go from doubling its
brain in a million years or 10 million
years or whatever the fuck it wasn't a
short period of time.
How did this thing become this thing and
why this persistent looked to the
heavens for answers.
Why?
Why Has God in the heavens?
Why can't God be inside of us?
Why can't God be in the middle of this
earth?
Why is he in the heavens?
Sure.
Because the fucking come from.
That's where the angels are coming from,
man.
Come on.
I got to spell it out for you.
Little tiny people that fly.
They're fucking aliens,
man.
They're coming down.
The grabbing the monkeys,
they're going to Tj's numb.
They had to take them up.
In the end,
they're going to take him up there and
do some experiments.
Ah,
how confusing be so awesome.
If it was so true to be fucked by an
alien,
be the best,
probably the best.
He'd probably be really bummed out with
people.
You only have one dick.
Dude,
aliens have like 30 dicks.
We put them everywhere in your body like
I don't even like dicks.
They're dicks or like ecstasy.
Tasers.
Ah,
great.
Imagine their Dick was like an ecstasy
taser.
If like the female opposite of a Taser.
Everybody has dicks.
They open up their jacket.
Like those dudes,
it would sell watches and they reveal a
thousand dicks.
Just swing out and grab a hold.
You in.
Ecstasy.
Tastes fresh eggs and not dick's.
They're like a technical type thing.
That's what they say.
But I keep feeling that comes inside
yet,
but they're come is ecstasy.
Don't worry.
Human.
This is not a date.
I know.
It looks like a Dick and tastes like a
dick.
Yeah,
that seems like a really inefficient way
to harvest gold though,
man.
It's like it.
These are,
you know,
the problem with those theories is like
here you've got these advance super
advanced beings.
They lay live on a planet that orbits,
they figured out a way to like disperse
golden,
their atmosphere.
They've figured out a way to like evolve
monkeys into gold miners,
but it's like,
man,
there's gotta be a bet.
It's gotta be a better way to do that.
A more efficient way than like flying on
your planet to another planet.
Fucking the monkeys turning them into
gold gathers.
Why?
Why is that the only way?
Like it seems like it's not the only
way,
but maybe it's,
it's the funnest way.
Maybe it's a good way like,
but what do they give a fuck?
They're probably so far advanced from us
that it's a joke.
It's hilarious to go down there and do.
That's fun.
Yeah.
Seaworld,
seaworld with people or it's just a kid
does it.
That's just like a group of kids for
their science.
Yeah.
There's,
there's just no telling.
Right.
But well,
who knows?
By the time they come back around,
they might be over it.
They might be so evolved after the 3,600
years.
If evolution is exponential,
they might come back and not even talk
to us.
Then people be like,
are they just decided to not come back?
Just fly by and go,
president trump,
trump.
That's going to be like,
they're going to sky ride it.
President trump,
sorry.
When I'm talking to you and they're just
gonna fly by like,
wait,
we can't really get to them.
Yeah,
because it takes too long.
Right.
You know,
like it's like Mars,
like they're talking about getting to
Mars know,
like a few decades.
I'll believe it when I see it.
Right.
I believe when I see it right now,
you can't get to it.
So if that fucking planet comes
searching some scorching around the
corner between Mars and Jupiter,
we're going to go,
hey,
wait,
come back.
What's the prediction of when it's going
to get here?
Well,
they don't know if it's ever going to
get here.
This what they found,
they don't know the orbit of it.
They don't do anything.
But there's,
this is,
it's all connected to the reason why
Pluto was taken off of the planet list.
They
realized that Pluto is just a body in
what's called the Kuyper belt.
The kuiper belt is just on the edge of
our solar system and there's a drop off
at the end of it that they called the
galactic shelf.
Right.
And that has been indicating to some,
some scientists who are willing to
venture and willing to explore the idea
that there's a large,
massive body outside of that that's
causing this dropoff that's caused
causing this galactic shelf.
So as their understanding of our solar
system gets better,
noticeably like wider,
like as as they can look further back
and further distances,
telescopes keep getting better and their
calculations and the way they can figure
out how the spot planets in other solar
systems,
they're way better at it now than
they've ever been before.
That's when they're pretty sure they're
like,
we're pretty sure there's another planet
out there,
but it could,
there's also some speculation.
We,
there was a few decades ago that it
could be a brown dwarf star,
right?
We could have a bio nary a solar system
that in fact many source systems are
binary.
Meaning there's more than one planet.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a single one and then there's a,
there's the one that we have that's on
right now and there's one that burned
out already and that burned out.
One is,
is way the fuck out there where it
doesn't emit any light anymore.
So this is this massive object outside
of Pluto.
So that was one theory that they had,
but I don't think they go with that one
anymore because as far as I'm,
I know they've narrowed down the size of
this thing,
at least with the current data to be
about four times the size of the earth.
So there's something four times the size
of the earth and just still tiny in
comparison to the son and he,
and tiny,
even comparison to Jupiter,
the sun is a million times bigger than
the earth.
So if this thing is four times larger
than the earth,
well I don't know what that means.
If it's a planet or if it's a,
you know,
a giant object.
Like what exactly is it?
Did it used to be a son?
Is that possible?
I don't know if that's probably,
I don't know.
Find out how big it's supposed to be.
Cause I'm pretty sure I'm right that
they're thinking now with their current
data that it might be four times as big
as the earth,
which is still pretty fucking trippy.
That there's some rock spinning around
out there that's a planet bigger than
it.
It isn't like cupid are way bigger than
cooper does on a real planet though.
I mean it is a plas to gas chain.
Yeah.
Like there's a center somewhere in
there.
Yeah.
It's like a tootsie roll pop.
I don't know how many licks it takes to
get there though.
It's a very big town.
It's so big.
They have storms on Jupiter.
They're bigger than earth.
They've been going on for a thousand
years.
Did you,
um,
did you follow this thing with a
detection of the gravity waves?
Yes.
That's pretty crazy.
I don't understand that.
I'm too stupid.
Well,
I think I can explain it.
I'm to try.
So,
uh,
so,
okay.
So the idea is right,
we know that the,
the fucking lead ball on the mattress
creates these d indentations in space
and time,
right?
Right.
So the idea is if that's the case in
timespace as they say,
so that if that's the case and you guys,
I'll probably fuck it up.
I'm going to track.
If that's the case,
then what would
happen if two super massive things
collided,
right?
Like two giant black holes,
thousands of times larger than our sun
or two stars or what?
What happens out there?
If these giant things collide,
then that should create ripples because
it's so,
uh,
normous that when they hit together,
it creates these ripples in the fabric
of space time.
And these are known as gravity waves,
right?
So to measure these ripples would be
incredibly difficult for a lot of
reasons.
One,
because I they're very fast.
The other one is because if I'm like,
okay,
so if I want to measure like the
distance between two rocks and a gravity
wave flows through it,
then it should theoretically since it's
a oh it should couldn't,
it should expand and like widen out the
distance between those two rocks.
There's going to be like a expansion is
the thing rolls through it it by micron
by a tiny little bit.
It's going to either widen or linkedin
or both.
I think both.
So for a second.
So how do I measure that?
If when the gravity wave passes through,
it's also going to make my measurement
device expand and contract and it's also
going to make me country expanding
contracts.
There was no way to measure it because
everything will move with it.
So how do you measure it?
So they have this thing called an infor
in fear or Ramadan or or something.
And for amateur,
you can look it up as this giant l shape
thing that shoots a laser that hits a
mirror on one side and shoots a laser
that hits a mirror on the other side
creating this beam.
And that's the speed of light,
right?
It's the laser bouncing back and forth
at the speed of light.
So that means that it could measure a
shift in the gravitational wave because
nothing goes faster than the speed of
light,
which means that that laser,
you're going to be able to tell if it
follows the prediction of what would
happen if a gravity wave rolled through,
right?
There's two of these things,
uh,
and there are hundreds of miles apart.
So if a gravity wave rolls through the
earth,
than both of them would theoretically
have these exact same minor shifts,
right?
And so that's what happened,
man.
They like now when they're doing these,
uh,
when they're doing these studies,
when they're testing,
they act,
they will,
they send in fake gravity waves just to
make sure the scientists are monitoring
everything,
writing it.
And so,
uh,
the guy who observed it for the first
time got this reading and I was like,
Holy Shit,
is this one of the fake,
uh,
one of the fake waves that they send
through,
but that he realized that they had cut
off that part of the experiment for a
few weeks.
So he knew they weren't doing that.
I'm,
I'm lost you there.
So anyway,
the point is,
it was like the story of them like
discovering this is,
is a amazing,
because finally this like shift
happened,
but the,
the,
the long and short of it is look at what
it picked up.
Like show what it was picking up.
It picked up these two
smashing into each other along far,
far away,
like a billion years ago.
Picked it.
I know that it's nuts.
Look,
look at that.
It's fucking,
I mean,
that's obviously not the real picture,
but,
um,
I just something insane to think that,
uh,
you know,
what's fucked up?
That is not the real picture.
But now the real pictures that they do
have of what's going on in the galaxy.
You ever see a picture of a stellar
nursery now?
I mean I've seen the Hubble picks,
if that's what you're talking about.
You know what a stellar nursery.
I was like where stars are born.
Uh,
you mean like with this huge,
show me a picture.
I bet.
I've seen there's the structures that
appear.
A lot of the pictures that you see,
the or artist's recreation,
a lot of them,
cause there's a lot of weird shit that
you see on the Internet.
You're like,
is that wait,
can we see that for real?
Like this is planets here.
Like this is like,
look,
what the fuck are you looking at there?
Look at that.
That's a stellar nursery.
That's a nursery.
Like were stars are ejected out into the
universe or from this gigantic
structure.
That's probably,
you know,
how fucking bigots and how hot is it
over there?
Can we even understand how big that is?
I mean,
does that even register in our stupid
little brains?
I mean,
if you looked at a photo of the earth in
perspective,
what would,
would it even be visible on that screen?
It would be pro.
You would probably need to blow it up a
million times.
You see the earth,
you need a microscope.
You'd have to look at the fuck.
Is that,
what is that?
Is that a demon flying through spats it,
it looks like,
but is that real or is that a photo?
Is that a photo pass?
Telescope captured it.
What the fuck man.
What is that?
That's crazy.
Like just understand for a moment.
Just try to wrap your head around the
idea that those are infinite sons.
Those are all sons,
little dots,
little stars,
most of them way bigger than our son and
they're all over the fucking place and
it just goes on forever.
Like our brains can't do it.
We can't,
there's no perspective.
Like email today we were talking and uh,
and I asked you how far are you shooting
your bow?
And you're like,
well,
I've done some calculations in my phone.
I see 50 yards.
I go,
wow,
you shooting 50 yards?
You're like,
yeah,
go,
that's amazing.
And then we go outside and I brought you
to a target that was 20 yards away and
you're like,
aw man,
I can't shoot that far.
Yeah,
like that.
That was a hard moment for me,
but just we had an actual detector see
like it's really hard to just judge
based on like taking footsteps and,
but with those range finders,
they have these range where we have one
in here somewhere.
This one right here,
this one.
This is a,
this is what I think that one's for
golf,
but you,
you press a button on that sucker and it
an x on the screen.
The other side holding it wrong.
Don't,
don't cover the lens.
You press a button on it and it'll show
you how far thing.
This is probably too close to using
here,
right?
Most of them need at least like 10 yards
or some,
sometimes more,
sometimes 15 yards.
Like the binocular ones.
They have binocular ones that work that
way.
They need like 30 yards.
Anything inside of 30 yards.
I can't detect.
But you,
we,
we use that and then you get this
perspective and that's 20 yards to tiny
distance.
Our sense of what infinity,
infinity and infinity,
our sense of the infinite space that's
in,
in the universe,
the idea of a stellar nursery being a
hundred million light years or whatever
the fuck it is away from us.
We can't,
we can't,
we can't.
We can't imagine.
It's not available to us.
We still have the same little fucking
monkey brain.
And I was looking at this thing the
other day of chimps where they showed,
uh,
we,
we showed her on the podcast the size of
a chimp sprain in comparison to side of
the size of his testicles.
It's insane.
They're really close.
Yeah.
Testicles are like that big.
And his brain is like double the size of
his.
No Way.
Oh yeah.
Look,
oh God.
That poor champ.
That's how we ended up.
You poor guy.
How Sad.
So imagine with our,
our balls,
which are smaller than his and our
brains,
which are larger than his,
and then it's just going to keep going
in that direction.
Okay,
but what,
what?
What we're,
what we're dealing with here is this an
advanced version of that we need way
better.
We need a better meat wagon.
Yeah.
In order to be able to comprehend these
numbers,
right.
In order to be able to figure out what
the,
what does infinity mean?
What does,
what does it mean?
What does a stellar nursery,
what is infinite space?
What is time?
What is gravity?
What is all this?
We're,
we're like repeating shit.
Have these super fucking geniuses have
worked their whole life on and we're
butchering it and ruining it in a
podcast.
But what we're,
we're,
we're all doing is we're all slowly but
surely going to go from being that chimp
to being some new thing.
Just continue to do it to continue to
grow,
continue to process and whether it's
through technology or whether it's
through manipulating our genetics,
we're going to become something that
gets this whole thing.
We're going to become some new,
some new things.
Here's the crazy idea,
man.
You're already that thing.
Here's what this is where it gets really
fascinating.
It's like you're already that thing.
That's the game.
The game is you're already that thing
pretending you're not the thing.
Doing some form of recreation that
involves being astounded by the
infinite,
enormous size of the universe because of
your particular tiny,
tiny,
tiny little body.
And so the gate,
that's,
that's the game that we're involved in.
You are ready are everything
experiencing this very temporary oh
illusion of being somehow not a part of
everything.
You already are,
the everything,
your Adams,
your,
um,
your atomic makeup,
those atoms inside of you there
essentially infinite.
I,
they,
they will go on forever.
We've talked about this before,
but that's what you are.
You are infinity experiencing itself,
pretending that you don't know anything
at all.
And so this head in the sand and we were
talking about getting caught in,
caught up with your bills,
your relationship,
your hair or my boobs.
Symmetrical.
Am I a good person?
All of this stuff is very temporary,
fleeting,
uh,
experience that infinity is having as
you.
And so you are the thing like no matter
what technological enhancements that
happen that maybe makes you live longer,
maybe allows you to download your
consciousness,
a new computer experience a million
orgasms at once and wow,
any of these things,
you're still,
um,
you still are the,
you still are the infinite.
These are just distortions in the field
of experience.
The idea is,
and I think it's a very beautiful idea,
you don't need the God damn singularity
to experience this.
You don't need the singularity to
experience being something greater than
you.
You don't need to become a trans human.
You don't need to become an h plus.
You don't need to get a chip,
a neural implant in your brain.
You can,
if you just spend enough time sitting,
still experience what it's like to have
your identity dissolve for a second.
Not that easy little just sit still and
it's not just sitting still,
it's sitting still with a method sitting
still with an understanding of what
you're trying to achieve.
It's still sitting still with tools that
allow you to manage your consciousness
during this process.
Well,
you know,
you got to get better at it.
I think that if it,
well,
you only think it's a,
it's a,
I think it's a discipline.
It's a discipline,
but the idea of like,
so I mean,
there's so many different versions of
it.
So like,
you know,
some versions have very specific,
breathing patterns or ways that you're
going to like the,
the whatever your meditative technique
is it.
But then some of them just say,
look,
don't worry about all that bullshit.
Just find a place anywhere and sit down
for a second.
You know,
like,
I remember once I was asking my
girlfriend,
she was sitting,
we have this like a Pooja table at our
house is what it's called.
Highly recommend.
It sounds cheesy,
but it's fantastic.
Create a little space.
Put in that space.
People that you love,
people that inspire you,
people who are awesome doesn't have to
be Jesus,
the Virgin Mary.
It could be anybody you're inspired by
creative space with these pictures.
And then maybe throw a picture on there
as somebody that you fucking hate and
you sit in front of this uh,
thing and you just like,
look at these people that you love and
then maybe you at the person that you
don't like so much and you try to
transfer that love to that person to
clear out the Guy Dan winning.
Whenever you hate anybody,
your operating systems got a bit of a
disturbance in it.
So you want to like fix that connection
if you can.
But anyway,
she's just sitting in front of this,
uh,
Pooja table.
We haven't,
I asked her,
are you meditating?
I shouldn't have done that.
It's rude if someone's meditating.
But I'm like,
are you meditating?
She's like,
now I'm just sitting here.
I thought that was so funny because it's
like,
oh right,
you're not,
you're not officially meditating,
you're just sitting.
But if you look at what zen means or
what someone told me,
[inaudible] means the zen meditation,
it means just sit.
There's no big anything to it.
There's not some fabulous,
incredible,
insane thing you're doing.
Just ask yourself,
when was the last time I sat and didn't
move for five minutes?
When was that?
When was it?
I think you're,
you're,
you're looking for all the same things
in so many different things that we do.
I think we're all looking for this
moment where everything sort of syncs up
and make sense and feels harmonious,
you know,
and I think,
I hate to bring it back to archery
again,
but I think that's what you're really
enjoying about those moments when you
release that Arrow.
Like I'm seeing,
I watched you a shoot some arrows today
and I'm seeing like this pleasure in
you.
Like when you're,
you're in the proper stance and you're
releasing the Arrow and you're watching
the path and everything looks good and
you're releasing it and there's this,
when you have mastered that moment,
even for a second or two,
you see this?
Yeah.
See this burst of off the bat,
you're not there anymore and your
existing through the shots,
it man,
your existing through your jokes,
you're existing through a rant on a
podcast you're existing through making
your girlfriend come your existing
through waving to a friend,
your existing through the experience
that you give other people when they're
around you.
Yeah.
Your existing through those things.
You know,
and those,
when you nail it in all forms,
it's all,
they're all similar and related.
That's right,
man.
They're all,
they all have at their core the same
thing.
It's,
it's,
you're at,
you're touching the core of what you
really are and,
and you know,
that's why meditation is,
I think is so incredibly misunderstood.
Uh,
and something that really isn't,
isn't,
isn't that different from any other
thing that you're doing.
Boat
float tanks,
right.
Float tanks is,
it is,
that's the real meditation.
That's meditation advanced.
If you want a vacation from life in an
ability to step back and really look at
yourself,
yeah.
You could sit in the corner and you
could just do it that way and there's
nothing wrong with doing it that way.
There's nothing wrong with going out on
a hill and sitting in and just
overlooking a beautiful field and taking
in nature and in meditating in that way.
That's a meditation in another.
Sure.
It's almost like an energy absorption.
Like you taking some power off the
battery,
like you're feeding it,
you're feeding off of it,
but the float tank is where it's at,
man,
and that those fucking things are
exploding now.
People are it now
for the first time in decades,
how important those things are.
There was this big,
a story that I printed the other day
about the basketball team,
the,
the um,
was the golden state warriors.
They use it every week.
Make sense?
Dude,
the fucking biggest one in the world
just opened up in Pasadena,
just float,
float lab.
Just open up one in Westwood.
They opened up a big location in
Westwood.
They're exploding now.
They're everywhere.
They're all over the world.
People love it for finally getting it.
People are finally getting it.
This thing is like the best way to have
a vacation from your thoughts or to be
alone with them rather have vacation
from your body I should say.
It's great cause you're,
you're peeling away all the goddamn
stimulus.
I mean bullshit.
I guess if there is like with
meditation,
if there was some kind of like well they
do call it a practice but the reason
they call it a practice it's because a
lot of meditation is like you're sitting
there and the dog will start barking.
Right.
Um,
got to kick it.
Right.
Well you got to throw it into the wall.
My die.
You have to see.
But you sort of like this is,
this is the,
I'm just kidding.
Of course guys,
when you're meditating you get up and
throw your dog.
But this is like a so,
so like a rom dass talks about like
giving this meditation class and people
are meditating and there was like a
siren that kept going off and people are
getting annoyed.
It was like buy a firehouse I guess.
So the fire truck would leave or the
fire truck would come in.
People are getting annoyed.
He can't meditate.
There's always a siren.
And he's like,
that's just energy.
Like you were hearing.
This is just energy going into your body
and your body is turning into the sound
of a siren.
But this is just grist for the mill is
what he called it.
This is just another form that the
universe takes the sound of a siren.
And so when you're meditating,
you start watching yourself,
right?
So and uh,
so the dog barked.
Like if I'm sitting meditating,
the dog would bark and I will watch
myself.
So now I watched the way that my body
reacts and the Dog Barks and the
physical,
kind of like a very slight tensing up to
inside a feeling fucking frustration who
struggled.
Shut the fuck up and net.
But I'm,
but now I'm watching that so well this
is what I do and I'm annoyed by
something.
And now you can watch the way that
annoying feeling emerges and dissipates.
And that's like the meditative process.
Whereas a float tank,
you're stripping that extra thing away.
So now it's just the sense of being
there,
minus having to deal with it
disturbances so much.
Even though they are in a float tank,
you'll still get some disturbances.
You know,
your,
you'll notice the way the air that
you're breathing or you'll feel some
burn where there's like a cut on your,
maybe a drop of water will land and hit
you in the head or something like that.
But we've got a squeegee the roof before
you go in.
That's a big part of it.
You know,
the,
um,
this guys who have invented some
workarounds for that,
there's a guy that owns a place in
Austin,
a zero gravity in Austin.
He's figured out a way to,
um,
he's got a different,
his,
his are made out of
like ship holes.
Yeah.
They don't trip,
don't trip.
And he's also got some sort of a,
a way to ventilate the a,
so there's no condensation on the,
on the roof of his tanks here and
credible.
That's Kevin Johnson.
Great Guy.
Cool Texas.
If you're there,
it's a great spot.
But,
um,
but mine,
I just give it a once over with the
squeegee when I climb in.
But those one of those things about like
the itches and the all the bullshit
other than the dripping of the water,
it's all in your head.
You just need to spend enough time in
those things.
Like I don't experience that anymore
when I get in the,
even if I have like a scratch,
like Jujitsu scratches were a problem
because like a lot of times dudes don't
trim the nails and you get really
scratched up.
But the good thing is the fucking salt
bath kills Era Thang Aero Thang.
I mean all the nasty funky shit on your
skin.
That's salt torches.
It cause you're talking about thousand
pounds of Epson Salts.
Super healthy for your body.
So you just gotta suffer through a few
seconds of stinging if you've got to
scratch but just breathe.
All you have to do is concentrate on
your breath.
The key to the tank is breathing in and
breathing out.
Just nothing.
But that put all of your energy on in
with the good and out with the bad.
With the good and out with the bath and
then I stopped assigning it a purpose.
I started assigning and get a,
uh,
like a quality or a positive or a
negative.
I just breathe and breathe in and I
don't allow myself every now and then,
my mind wants to start going about,
man,
you've got to work on that new bit.
That's new bins.
Fucking got a wheel hitch in it.
You've got to abandon this.
Shut the fuck up.
You're like,
ah man.
When are you going to fucking clean your
office?
Shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up and what I'm doing.
And then you can bypass the land of
trouble and confusion.
There's like a land of trouble and
confusion that takes about 20 minutes to
get through and you to,
she's fucking hustle through that land
and you've got to do the work.
You got to fucking concentrate on the
breathing because if you give in to the
land of trouble and confusion,
but let me just hang out here and talk
to you guys for awhile.
They'll fucking drag you into their
come.
Let's talk about your girlfriend from
high school.
Maybe if you guys got back together and
you'd be happy,
maybe Janine,
amazing story.
She's got kids,
you've got cage,
you both pick up,
you know,
like,
you know what I mean?
I'm pretty sure is a con.
Okay.
You always a con,
you gotta tell the fucking business
manager and you start having these like
wars in your head about your life that
are totally unnecessary and
counterintuitive to what you're trying
to do there.
We try and do there as escape,
escape the whole thing by concentrate.
That's why yoga is the shit because yoga
is hard to do.
Just like archery is hard to do when
you're standing there and you've got the
fucking one foot up and you're
stretching up like this and you're
holding it,
your whole body shaking and they're
like,
hold,
hold
and not thinking about anything other
than,
you know,
breathing and trying to do that because
he can't do it when you're,
when it's a swipe at that beak from
guy's a scumbag,
but he's,
he had a fucking great idea.
All right,
get a great idea.
Then 104 temperature to that tests your
will.
It does something to your brain.
Um,
Doctor Rhonda Patrick thinks it might
create something called heat shock
proteins that you get from a sauna.
Citizens,
there's a positive benefit health wise
to being in a sauna,
right?
Very positive.
To a point where she was saying that
there was a 40% reduction in mortalities
across the board from people that are
regular saw users,
40% reduction in cancers,
heart attacks,
stroke,
all those things,
massive mortality dropoff because the
sauna,
because your body produces these heat
shock proteins,
she's like,
it could very well be going on in those
classes.
You're so fucking hot right here.
Your body's overheating.
It's freaking the fuck out.
So 140 degrees in there and you're doing
unbelievably strenuous exercise.
I think there's all these different
methods that we have come up with,
whether it's martial arts,
whether it's yoga,
whether it's meditation,
whether it's the tank,
they're all trying to get away from the
influence of the fucking primate DNA,
right?
All of it.
The jealousy,
the tha,
tha tha tha tha wanton materialism.
The fucking anger and traffic and the
nonsense about your career and the
interpersonal relationship bullshit that
we put ourselves through back and forth.
A big part of it all is a perspective
that was inherited.
We inherited it from these fucking
barbarians,
right?
That came in each other and just barely
made it.
They fucking,
they did live to be 10 and they did fuck
somebody else and meet people.
We're probably getting pregnant when
they were six years old back then,
but who knows what the fuck.
We were like,
we're a month.
You know,
we had to become what we are today,
but we're trapped.
We're trapped with the momentum of that
shit in our bodies.
Trapped,
not trapped.
You can escape,
but hindered to the point where it
requires,
it requires input.
Well,
this is the w attached.
This is why I like the word attached.
You're attached to it.
You're cleaning to it.
You're holding onto it.
You're carrying around this like just a
fucking stinking corpse that you think
is who you are and you're clinging to
it.
That's the land that you're talking
about that you're going through and
people don't wanna let go of that
because that is what defines you.
That's everything that you are and
people want to be to find.
They would rather be defined then they
would be by being undefined.
Yeah,
but when you've,
okay,
so you've sailed through,
what did you call the land of trouble
and despair?
Yeah.
So you've sailed through the land of
trouble in his space.
That's 20 minutes.
So what's after that?
How would you describe the state after
that?
The state after that is where it gets
psychedelic.
The state after that is where you,
you don't exist anymore and you're just,
you're intertwining yourself with
information and ideas and these ideas
are bouncing around your head,
but you don't really consider yourself
as you is.
If you do,
you'll snap out of it.
One of the weirder things about the
psychedelic trance that you get from the
tank is that it's so pliable and go in
it and out of it and sometimes I lose it
and I'm done.
I'm just laying there for the next hour,
for the next hour it's gone.
I'll brie.
They'll do,
but it was whatever it was was such a
whipple,
such a right,
so strange and odd and bizarre and non
non non dimensional.
It doesn't,
doesn't pertain to anything that you
experienced in this dimension.
So you become something when your body
is free of your mind,
when your mind is free of your past,
when you just,
you escape.
It's almost like you're pulling your,
it's like almost like a gravitational
pull or an atmosphere rather.
Well you pop out of that atmosphere like
a rocket that shoots up into space and
you float around for a little while.
Then you come back down and deal with
the bullshit again.
But you're,
when you pop out of the land of trouble
and despair,
it's like you're floating in zero
gravity because you're in the tank.
You literally feel like you're in zero
gravity because you don't feel anything
anymore because once you've relaxed to
the point where the water is no longer
distinguishable,
the air and the water,
the same thing and you just feel like
you're floating.
That's where it's at,
man.
You've got to get to that space when you
bought is just totally stopped moving
and when you get to that space in your
body is totally stopped moving and
you've gone through the land of trouble
and despair.
You just get to the place of just
thought.
You get to the place of thought.
That's free of all the culture and
tradition and even language to a certain
extent.
The thoughts stop being like you're
relaying things in your head in
sentences and paragraphs.
It,
it becomes concepts and ideas that are
almost alien to language gets very
weird.
Yeah.
Especially when you're on edibles.
Ah,
I can only imagine.
Why don't you do it more often?
Because my tank,
my zen tank,
we moved and I put it in the garage and
I just haven't set it up.
That's all.
I got to clean the garage out.
I gotta order more salt.
It's all my fault.
I loved that thing.
It was so nice.
I was so nice going in there after a
workout,
just going in and just went on.
Understand that you don't have it fading
and I got to get it set up again.
I just have to set it up.
I've got to call someone.
Do you have to do it yourself?
No,
I think,
uh,
I can to call those zen people.
Go Yo Hook.
No,
he's,
I think he's going to be in town to do
another podcast.
I'm gonna get you to help me set it up
again.
But it's not that I,
it's that is part of it.
But the other part of it is I've got a
fucking shit ton of quarter.
Like I have a hoarder problem in my
garage.
And do you think your office is bad?
Man?
My garage looks there could be a dead
animal in that.
Like I've got so much shit piled up.
I got to clean it out.
And if I just did that,
I would have a float tank.
But also the other cool thing is I live
right down the street from just float.
Oh yeah,
I can go down there and Jim has been
really cool and letting me like float
there.
So it's awesome.
That's great.
Yeah.
Oh that's nice.
It's so luxurious.
Those voices are booming now.
They're booming solo.
It's so cool.
Yeah.
And they should be man,
because,
but this,
this place you're talking about man,
uh,
the place that you're accessing through
the float tank and not always,
by the way,
sometimes I just go float.
Well,
the idea is you're always there.
You're there right now.
Like that place you're talking about,
you're there right now.
It's just that your attention has been
consumed by all the phenomena that are
swirling around you at this moment
called your podcast.
So you're there right now and that the,
the practice of mindfulness and whatever
way you can practice mindfulness in a
float tank,
Zendo in your car,
wherever you want,
the practice of mindfulness is helping
you at least maybe not shoot out of the
gravity of the planet,
of your personality,
but at least like get into the air a
little bit instead of getting cause this
land of what does it,
sorry.
Trouble in the land of trouble and
despair.
This is like the discursive mind,
right?
So this is like a,
you know,
the,
the idea that uh,
there are two arrows strikes,
right?
So in,
in every single given moment,
there are all these phenomena that are
happening.
Some of the phenomena,
you don't notice some of the phenomena
you do,
but there's two Arrow strikes.
One of them is the initial one that
bothers you.
Like somebody cuts you off in traffic,
right?
So someone cuts you off in traffic.
It's a classic example and you go,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Jesus fucking Christ.
So it was wrecked,
right?
Arrow strike the first air strike is the
guy cutting you off in traffic.
The second Arrow strike and the poison
arrow is everything that follows.
Now you're in the land of trouble and
it's fair.
Now your mind has become this echo
chamber bouncing around with all these
thoughts of like,
God damn it,
people are fucking assholes.
No one cares about no though.
Everyone's so fucking selfish.
God,
that fucking asshole at work earlier
today.
Suck man.
Yeah,
that's just salt.
And so now,
and that's called,
that's called getting lost,
right?
That's called getting lost.
So flow tanks,
meditation.
These are things where instead of
getting sucked in to the conversation,
like you were saying with the Ma many
entities that live in this land,
you just let that first thing hit you.
I've been cut off in traffic and then it
goes away and there might be these
thoughts flying around in your head
like,
Oh God,
what an asshole.
People suck.
But instead of you reacting to those
thoughts,
you just watch them like,
oh wow,
that's the part of my brain that thinks
people suck.
Watch that.
Wow,
there it is and now it's gone.
And that practice makes you a much
happier person over time and you realize
what conflicts are real and what
conflicts are just artificial,
which ones you've made up,
which ones you've just,
and you've endorsed,
you've given them license to,
to participate in your emotions,
but they really don't exist at all.
The nonsense nonsense.
Someone cutting you off with nothing
even happened.
You didn't get in an accident?
No.
Oh,
so you ran into an asshole.
Welcome to Earth.
Yeah,
there's a lot of them.
Right.
And guaranteed.
He didn't mean to like he did.
You know,
once,
once man,
I was like trying to like,
I,
I couldn't,
I was late to get radiation therapy.
Uh,
and I,
I cut somebody off in traffic cause I
had to go get my fucking body radiated
at a God damn radiation clinic and I'm
like,
I'm sick and I cut some off in traffic
and I remember they're like,
fuck yeah,
fuck yeah.
Or
I'm like,
man,
I've got cancer,
dude.
I'm getting fried down in this clinic.
Trust me.
I'm,
I'm like,
but now when any wood cuts me off,
usually I just think,
man,
I bet that guy's going to get radiation
therapy,
man.
Let's give him a fucking break today.
You don't know where he's going.
You know,
she might just be getting back from an
abortion.
Like you don't understand what's
actually happening there.
And so if you let your mind trick you,
then you'll get lost.
And that's the,
that's the problem is it's like,
it's not the screaming after the guy
cuts you off.
It's when you realize that for the last
six years you've been reacting to
somebody,
cutting you off in traffic and it's
somebody you did some shitty thing to
you six years ago and you're still in
the fucking car,
you're still banging the seat.
Well,
how frustrating is it when you're dating
someone and they bring up some shit that
you argued with them about six months
ago and the worst,
the worst,
the worst.
Summoning up,
summoning up this demon from the past
and then like puppeteering it,
you know,
like remember this Diarra member?
Do you remember you did that,
you did that and you could be talking
about something that happened right now
like Jesus Christ.
Did you leave the refrigerator door
open?
You fucking left the garage door opened
a year ago and I still haven't found my
bike.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What happened there?
It's,
I just asked you if you'd like to
refrigerator to open.
Yeah,
a fucking crazy bitch.
And then you realize live in a bad
neighborhood,
but then you really realize that crazy
bitch lives in your brain because your
brain,
your brain is always bringing that shit
out her brain.
How about fixing her brain?
She sat next to you.
You don't need to
start with the crazy girlfriend living
in your consciousness because that,
that that's the one that's causing you
all the problems.
If but what if you live in when the
girls crazier than the crazy girl in
your consciousness is like,
yeah,
so this is like a,
I think a problem many people have to
deal with man,
which is like all right.
A lot of times you hear it like my
fucking parents are fucking out of their
mind,
you know?
And so you want to like change your
parents or you want to change the person
you're living.
Where do you want to change your kids
and a man?
I'm telling you if you really look at
the,
I really like that a,
I've talked about it before.
If I really liked that Clint Eastwood
movie play misty for me it's like this
all you can get on.
I think on itunes it's really good,
but this guy ends up fucking a fan and
the fan ends up,
uh,
stalking him.
But you realize that he was playing the
game with,
with this girl that he had fucked.
Like he was letting her in every single
time he was giving her a little bit of
something to move on.
Right?
And like if you're living with a crazy
person and you really analyze the game,
there are some rules of the game.
I'll tell you a few right away.
Number one,
you need a crazy person.
That's the first one.
So you decide this is a crazy person,
right?
That's rule number one.
I'm living with a fucking crazy person,
I guess.
Really?
Well guess who's really fucking crazy?
The person who's decided to live with a
crazy person.
So there's two crazy people in the
house.
Well,
people change
their behavior though for you.
And then once you move in with them,
you realize how nutty they are.
Unless you're like super fucking
critical and objective and really
analyzing someone's behavior and you do
a background check.
I mean,
how many girls are room moved in with a
guy and they find out who was abusive
piece of shit once they got in that
you're right.
That's true.
How many guys have been with a girl?
And then as the relationship goes on,
they start to blame you for their
failures in life and you become the
magnifying glass of all their
personality and perfection.
Get the fuck out of there.
But that's,
that's the only answer then.
But like if you're,
but yeah,
a lot of times,
a lot of times though,
man,
a lot of times if you look at,
and I don't just mean living with a
girl,
I mean living with anyone.
But if you look or being at work with
anyone or anyone you interact with on a
daily basis,
he,
you haven't,
uh,
some weird shit with right now.
The next time you're interacting with
them in a bat to get in the old classic
fight,
you know,
just watch yourself.
Just watch yourself gear up.
And you will notice a lot of the time
that you're the one who's getting into
this shit,
that you're the ones you want it to
happen.
You might notice a lot of the time,
I'm not saying that this is always the,
this sounds super personal.
Why I,
well that's all I got is myself.
That's how the guys,
myself and this is like,
so this is the,
uh,
the concept is Shempa I've talked to,
I think I've talked about in the
podcast,
it's,
it's something Pema chodron talks about,
which is a guy,
we're going back to archer again.
So shempa is the feeling of pulling back
the bowstring or the feeling of
preparing to strike,
right?
So with mindfulness you start learning
about that feeling,
right?
So someone starts pissing you off,
who start preparing for battle.
You prepare for that and you realize
the,
your insults,
you want to be right.
You've pulled back the bow and you want
to be right.
Really,
you want to put the fucking couch there
really?
Because I just don't think it belongs
there.
He want to put the fucking couch there.
Now,
if you think about is there a right
place for the couch and the universe
that we were just talking about much?
Don't put the cows in front of the
fireplace,
he'll catch on shore.
You're stupid foot.
Aesthetically we exist in a universe was
star clusters that are giving birth to
stars and you have decided this must be
the right place for the couch,
right?
And that Shempa you're pulling it back.
You're going to fight this stupid fight
when instead you could be like,
you know what?
Yeah,
that's a perfect place for the cat.
You know what happens when you do that?
You end up with a fucking chick house
and they dominate the whole place.
They start with a couch and then they
moved to the fucking sheets and next
thing you know your toothbrush,
balance,
fluffy fucking fluffy cover over your
pillows.
You got Valentine's heart to hanging on
your Buddhists.
That's my five year old.
Put that up.
I love it man.
And sure you end up with that.
You end up with a chick house,
but you know that's a little girl house.
That's slightly different than Chai.
We'll take chick houses different,
they'll start,
they'll start fucking putting scented
candles around.
You'll come home some music and kate
will be planned and just let me listen.
This one.
So here's what your mind just gay put
headphones on while you're on your
computer.
It's your care.
What I play really loud.
That's awful.
That would,
that's what you see.
Here's what the mind does.
A thing happens.
The couch fight the mind.
Instead of just thinking like in this
moment I'm getting in a fight and inside
of me,
my level of passion over this fucking
couch,
it's like I'm fighting for my life.
So then you look at the,
well,
why am I getting so upset about this?
Because the mind is telling you,
mother fucker,
if this couch and stuff here,
it's going to be a matter of time before
she starts fucking a personal trainer
for a few.
Yeah.
If she starts fucking her trainer,
you're going to be wearing dresses.
You're going to,
you're going to end up,
you're gonna end up sucking or trainers
cock and you're going to meet a chick
house.
That's the mind telling us what I'm
saying.
Dude,
it's not real.
It's not real.
It's not as slippery as a battle going
on.
Try to lose,
lose the battle.
I'm telling you right now,
if you have a mortgage,
don't lose the battle.
Don't lose the battle over the mortgage.
Don't lose the battle.
If you know,
if she wants you to sign up,
she doesn't want you to sign a prenup.
Don't lose the bag.
No,
I'm not talking about those battles.
I'm as a real man.
Those are real battles.
I'm consequences.
I'm talking about in general,
most battles that you're fighting,
they don't have that much of a
consequence,
and if you really want to talk about
losing the fucking battle,
and I'm not talking about rolling over
for your girlfriend or for your boss,
if for any of these people I'm talking
about those little tiny conflicts you
create so that you can feel what it's
like to overpower someone in win in
every single moment,
the winning thing,
I'm going to win.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's like the most toxic thing in a
relationship,
right?
If you're with a girl and it's,
it becomes,
there wasn't a billy Joel Song about
that matter of trust.
Just leave,
just lose practice losing.
And I
live in with,
how about,
here's the thing though,
I definitely believe that you're correct
in that you will attract the type of
people that you deserve in that sense
that you deserve with the way you
believe.
And the way you could run it in nutty
people,
you can fuck up.
You could say he could as ag for the
most part,
the people that you let in a lot,
a lot of times they reflect where you
are as person.
So if you find yourself involved in
these shitty relationships over and over
again,
you might want to look inward.
You might want to look at what you're
putting out there and what kind of
people you're letting in and what kind
of circles you're hanging around in and
what kind of interest you're pursuing,
what kind of things you focusing on and
why is that led you to be engulfed in
this world of stupid?
Well,
and,
and yeah,
and in the world of stupid,
the era,
and it's like you're in the world of
stupid fine.
You,
you got into the world of stupid
whatever.
But really if you start looking at like
this is,
they call it threading the necklace,
right?
You're threading the fucking necklace
every single moment you're threading,
this necklace is suffering.
So in every single moment
you're bringing into that moment,
all the past battles,
you lost,
all the past battles you want,
all the compromises you made.
You're bringing into that moment your
idea of here's what's right and here's
what's wrong.
And the question is how much of your
understanding of what's right and how
much of your understanding of what's
wrong is based on reality and how much
of it is based on your own desire to
win,
to overcome.
Then again,
man,
I'm not,
I'm not advocating the concept of
becoming someone who's downtrodden and
some girl or boss or situation is like
clumping all over you.
But yeah,
I'll tell you again,
a fight with my girlfriend,
uh,
like,
a few months ago,
and I'm,
I'm sorry,
core of this is to purse.
I got this stupid fight.
She's got a picture of Bob Dylan,
right?
Big,
big picture of Bob Dylan and were nice
framed,
beautiful,
original print of Bob Dylan.
Right.
I don't like Bob Dylan.
You know,
I don't like him.
He is,
don't you like him?
Because,
because he,
he,
I saw an interview that he did when he
was like a super con.
This is before the Kanye thing happened
and you know,
now that I think about it,
why don't I like Bob Dylan,
he's got a lot of great fucking songs.
Even though if he sat,
he sounds like a wallet,
a leather wallet started singing or
something.
It's like,
I don't know why it annoys me.
And I like,
it doesn't matter.
I thought there's no real basis of
liking and not liking
it anyway.
Like,
so my,
so I have a bad identification.
So she's got this cool picture of Bob
Dylan and she wants to put it in the
guestroom.
Right,
right.
And I'm like,
fuck that fucking picture,
man.
You going to put,
I got really mad.
Like I don't want to fucking Bob Dylan
and the in the,
in the fucking guestroom.
You were explaining what it was that you
said before Kanya you got dust side.
You were saying there was a thing that
he did an interview that he,
Oh yeah,
he was just conti to some reporter or
whatever.
I don't know.
Maybe he's having a bad day.
People love Bob Dylan was when he was
young.
Yeah,
he's young.
Whatever.
It's,
it's not,
it doesn't matter.
He did nothing.
It's Bob Dylan is a great performer and
who the fuck am I to judge him?
My egoic brain doesn't like Bob Dylan
and it still doesn't like Bob Dylan.
I can't make myself like if I don't like
to listen to his music.
Oh No.
The watchtower.
I don't think it's a basis.
Obviously I'm not,
I don't think it's based in reality,
but so like,
you know,
I'm like,
I don't want that picture up.
I don't want that picture of Bob Dylan
up in the guest.
I'm like,
I don't want our guests to look at Bob
Dylan.
I'm being a dick man and like you know
what she does man,
puts it up there.
Anyway,
she takes it down and then like I come
into the guestroom and she's taken a
picture of Bob Dylan down and I'm like,
you took the picture of Bob Dylan down.
She's like,
yeah,
I guess I'll just sell it on Ebay or
something.
And like in that moment I felt like the
biggest asshole ever live like God damn
it man.
I wanted to win this battle.
I wanted to win,
I wanted to be the victor and I won.
What did I win a wall that doesn't have
Bob Dylan on it and like my girlfriend
like having like,
Oh I guess I'm just going to sell this
picture that I like cause my boyfriend's
a deck and it's like that's not winning.
That's losing like that's fundamentally
losing on every single level.
Now I guess if she'd been like using the
picture of Bob Dylan and some kind of
like method of torture,
like till when herself,
it's different.
But all I'm saying is a lot of times we
make decisions that we think are in our
own best interest when really there
because we want to feel like we have
one,
like we're right,
we want to be right,
and sometimes you're not right because
there's no right or wrong answer.
Right.
Let's get back to the root of why.
What are you doing in the first place?
Like why are you seeking conflict like
this?
I think for a lot of people it's because
of what we were talking about earlier,
these primal needs that are not met,
these primal genetic needs and some of
those primal genetic needs or about
overcoming situations.
Overcoming adversity.
Yeah.
There's reward systems built into our
brain.
That's why we give a fuck of a computer
beats us and go because we'd go is is a
test would test is something you tried
to overcome,
right?
You're trying to compete,
so this,
this wanting to win with your
girlfriend.
It's a manifestation of some shit that's
deep in our DNA.
It's not just as simple as lose or just
let it happen.
It's as simple as you have some
programming in your body that you need
to address with.
Uh,
there's,
there's certain activities that you can
pursue that can free you from all this
stupidity,
right?
It's tied up in you,
and it doesn't have to be that you,
you know,
you just let it go and you just lose.
Like there's,
there's,
there's other methodologies,
there's other ways to approach it.
And I think the holistic way is to do
the whole thing.
Let it be,
be aware of what the competition is,
but also drain your fucking body out of
all its excess energy because your body
is like an overflowing machine.
It's like a,
uh,
an engine.
There's too much gas pumping into,
right?
It's like choking and spitting on its
own energy.
It doesn't have an outlet.
You're in a fucking car all day.
You're drinking coffee all day,
or you're in a car in the morning,
you're drinking coffee all day.
You're stuck in a box.
You're sitting down,
you get up,
your back hurts,
you piss,
you fucking go back to work again.
You're barely moving.
You're barely moving and your body's
designed to run from cats.
Your body's designed to fucking build a
house because intruders or common it,
none of these needs are being met.
The needs of gathering up your own food.
That's why there's that primal,
crazy feeling when you catch a fish.
That feeling when you got to fish,
when you bring a holy Shit,
you could go to a store,
buy a fish.
It takes five seconds.
Yeah,
walk up to the counter.
give me one of those trout.
They prep it up.
They give it to you.
You're done,
but not does it feel like anything?
That's right.
It doesn't feel,
you know,
imagine if it felt that good to buy a
fish and when you bought a fish,
be like,
oh,
look at the size of his trout.
Wow.
Did you buy this?
Fish is amazing.
Where did you buy pictures of
everybody's instagram would be pictures
of the fish.
They just,
if you show a picture of fish on
instagram,
you'd better be cooking that thing.
You better be explaining some delicious
thing you,
but you could catch a fish.
You take a picture,
everybody goes,
aw man,
Nice Bass.
Right.
Good.
Yeah.
Right.
This is a primal thing.
That's right.
And that primal things attached to the
shoot and I was fucking arrows,
right.
Make no mistake about it.
They used to be an effective tool.
Oh No.
The more you do stuff like that,
the last you're going to fight over
fucking Bob Dylan pictures.
Guaranteed.
At least have to do that.
You just got to train the body,
make the body fucking move,
make it move,
get all that excess pull shit out of
you.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and the,
it's,
you're right,
it's exercise is certainly one big part
of it,
man.
But there's La,
it's all,
they're all connected,
all connect.
There is no,
there's no one thing that you,
you don't need.
And that whole puzzle,
the main,
I think the main thing that you teach is
that you don't have to be trapped and
the gravitational field of whatever the
particular wife is that you happen to
find yourself.
And if you find yourself in a life that
you don't like,
if you find yourself in a situation that
is not bringing you happiness,
then there are ways that you can escape.
That gravitational field takes work and
it takes time.
It takes a lot of momentum.
It takes time.
And that's a big one.
And a lot of people quit before they get
through their saw.
Crazy statistic.
A not a statistic or they're a meme that
is probably pretty accurate.
It said 97% of the people work for the
3% of the people that didn't quit.
Alright.
Yeah,
that's pretty good man.
And,
and,
but you know,
the whole quitting thing failing.
That's good too.
You can feel learn from them.
You learn.
Yeah.
The negative and positive feedback are
all important in the loop.
And the,
the,
the mind will tell you after you failed
a certain number of times that you will
never be able to do it.
I mean,
that's part of the thing.
That's the other trick of the mind.
The mind.
There's two,
the,
a lot of tricks than mine.
As one of the tricks.
The mind tells you this is the main
source of suffering for a lot of people
is that however you're feeling right now
is permanent.
So that's not the number one like bad
trip.
That's one big source of it.
You want to have a bad trip on acid when
you're in our three,
let your mind start telling you,
you're going to be like this forever.
I'm going to be like this forever,
man.
This is never going away.
Three hours.
I know this is never going to go.
It's near it and you will free.
You will freak.
You will freak out if you think you're
going to trip for infinity,
right?
So in the same way,
most suffering comes because people
think,
oh shit man,
this situation I'm in,
I had to always going to be like this.
I'm always going to be fat.
I'm always going to have a shitty job
and always going to be broke.
I'm always going to be sad.
I'm never going to get out of this hole.
That's a lie.
That's not true.
If you look at your life,
you've always experienced a change in
your emotional state.
You've always experienced the change in
literally every single thing from your
body to your surroundings,
do your jobs to your girlfriends,
boyfriends.
It all is in a constant of flux.
So when you realize that,
then you can let go of the panic that
comes when you start thinking like,
shit,
this is going to be like this forever.
No,
it's not.
It's not.
It's going to change.
Your situation will change.
And once you start understanding that,
then it gives you some room to work.
It gives you some room to actually begin
to make shifts or to do experiments,
man.
But the mind will tell you,
oh,
you have failed.
Look,
you got fat again.
You got fucking,
I got fat.
I um,
man,
I got,
I was working out nonstop equinox.
I got my body fat down to 16%,
Joe Rogan.
For me,
that's a big deal.
It's pretty good.
Cause I got,
I get fat and uh,
I swell up,
I throw those fucking beers down,
the old tube,
five slices of fucking bread,
a beer and I pumped,
I've get fat.
So then I went on tour and I got fucking
fat again man.
And like literally fat,
overweight.
Cause I,
this might,
equinox doesn't let you pretend that I
think I'm all right.
They measure your body fat and I go,
yeah,
you're overweight.
So I fail.
What'd you get up to percentage?
I don't want to say man,
I just got just,
I got,
I'll tell you the percentage I got to by
describing the look of sadness and my
trainers,
I,
when the fucking printer thing came out,
like a combination surprise.
He's like,
wow,
that's how fat I got.
So I'm still a faryal but it's,
it's diminishing.
I've been working out three times a
week,
but God dammit I'm going to keep fucking
doing it is a matter of practice.
I'm going to get fat,
fine.
But every time we get fat I'm going to
fight against it.
Why you saying that you're going to get
fat?
Well,
I'm just saying if I do again,
but why are you saying it that way?
You're right.
That's bad.
Well,
it seems like you're giving yourself a,
a loophole that's kind of fun to get fat
really.
Well,
I mean,
in the process of eating,
when you're there in the hall,
it's no fun.
But like in the process of shoving
pizzas,
dying your throat,
nobody's like that.
Like if that,
if that wasn't fun,
then we'd have a,
a very different,
uh,
it's very different shape of most
people.
And listen to everything that you just
said,
right?
But the way you thinking and hold on for
a second before you interject,
think about everything you're saying
about the way people think and about the
traps and the way you define your
patterns that you fall back into each
and every time.
Then think about the intense physical
health consequences that you have
intimately experienced.
And the fact that even though you've
gone through cancer,
yes,
you still will make yourself a like a
path that you're definitely going to go
down.
Where are you going to abuse your body,
right?
It put yourself into a state of shock
and overweight and making sure that you,
your body is compromised pretty
significantly.
Right?
You know,
when you,
when you really fat like that,
you're pretty significantly compromised
telling anybody,
tell you any different.
All those people that like want to dance
around it and say,
you know,
I'm fat and I'm healthy.
Like that's not real.
It's not real.
You are not as healthy as you would be
if you're not fat.
You can be fairly robust and overweight,
but you are,
you're
compromised.
It doesn't mean that you are not
functional,
but you're most certainly compromised,
right?
You were at your best when your optimal
and when,
when do you optimal your optimal when
you are at a low,
a fairly low body fat,
not,
not ridiculous.
You don't want to be shredded.
He want to be fairly healthy and you
want to have a lot of nutrients in your
diet and you want to keep your body away
from any bullshit,
right?
You want to keep your body way from any
fucking sugars and processed shit and
nitrates and all that fucking shit that
you get from.
Sure.
Sausage and Pepperoni and fucking Salami
sandwiches and coca cola and corn syrup,
all that shit that tastes so Gloria's
going down is killing your body.
It's true,
man.
So why after all that you just said,
would you give yourself that little,
the little loophole,
that little mouth pleasure.
You're right and know you're right,
it isn't.
Okay.
So we'll say,
okay.
Right,
so,
so like when we were talking about it
being intimate,
like this is very intimate.
It's great your talk,
but you're talking about you.
Yeah.
Right.
You are talking about you and you're
defining this,
this struggle and balance and battle.
And then at the end of this
inspirational thing,
you give yourself a loop.
All this is what I do.
I get fat and then that,
but when I get fat,
I get healthy again.
Fucking right.
All right.
Okay.
You're right.
It's,
it's gotta be like,
I think as I think about this,
right,
I do think about this,
right?
So why do I do this?
This loop,
this clear loop in my life,
which I it,
I've gone through a few repetitions of
this where I'll get close to getting in
shape.
I won't be what I would consider in
I'll get close and then I'll fuck it all
up.
So why am I building this house of cards
and then knocking it down again?
And especially after having gotten sick,
why would I keep doing that?
Right,
right.
So man,
I mean,
look,
I would love to have like a quick answer
for that awesome question.
But I don't,
I mean I could like,
yeah,
I don't know.
I could give some easy answer that like,
but it wouldn't be the right answer.
I really don't know.
You allow it.
Right.
Let's move it right now.
So it's what it all is.
You're right.
I'm not a victim,
right.
No.
Look,
there's a reason why you don't smoke
cigarettes,
right?
Yeah.
Cause you don't allow them,
right.
You allow all this other stuff.
You say,
I'm going to eat shitty food,
I'm going to get fat.
I love throwing beard on my face and
then you allow it,
right?
So you allow yourself some mouth
pleasure or some,
you know,
uh,
some alcohol in intoxication pleasure.
You'll allow yourself that.
Right.
And you suffer the health quants
consequences like readily you like you
just,
it's this part of the program.
The mouth pleasure is more important
than the health.
So you allow it.
Yeah,
that's it.
But you don't allow other shit,
you know,
like if somebody gave you a bottle
oxycontin's you wouldn't be like,
oh no,
I can't eat these all day.
I know.
Allow it.
Yeah.
Well I mean I'd probably take a couple.
You would too.
Right?
You like those things,
but yeah,
no,
I know what you mean,
man.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean allow it.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
I've gotten fat.
I've gotten pretty close to being fat.
Like for me,
for me,
I've gotten,
you know,
I can think of that the heaviest I got,
I was like two oh four or two oh five or
something like that.
That's 10 15 pounds overweight.
For me,
for real.
Like I really shouldn't,
like my face gets fat and good it,
I'll get it here.
I get it.
Like down here,
I started to get a little bit of this
and I could see it,
I could see it in my face,
I could see it in my sides,
you know?
And,
but that was all because I didn't work
out hard enough in relationship to how
much collars I was consuming.
Yeah.
It's not that I ever stopped working
out,
but I was eating too much.
I was eating too much for what I was
doing.
But I get to a point where I realize it
and then I go,
okay,
I see what we're doing here.
Don't get fat.
Get like kind of close to fat.
Realize what you're doing and don't do
it again.
If you allow yourself to get too far
gone,
then you create this fucking gigantic
divid that you can't get out of it.
It's the worst.
And I get,
if I got the worst I got like when I
hurt my back,
it was also what was going on to cause.
So what couldn't work out as intensely
when I was about 10 pounds heavier than
I am now.
The worst that it got was all wrapped
around like feeling sorry because of an
injury not being as disciplined as I
could be and allowing myself the
indulgence,
figuring I'm going to make up for it
later so I'm not,
I'm guilty of the same sort of behavior
I'm making you aware of by just,
I'm not guilty of it right now.
Like right now I'm on the straight and
narrow and I'm pretty healthy about it
and I'm pretty decided that this is how
many eat from now on with rare
indulgences just from mouth play.
But I think that mouth pleasure can't be
the big one.
I can't be,
it's just not good for you.
Now the big one should be health health
should be the big one.
Mouth pleasure should be the occasional
foray.
It can't be daily mouth pleasure.
God Damn.
It's like,
I'll tell you man,
like when I'm like shoving some kind of
shitty food into my mouth,
it's like such a,
it's got such a strong gravity for me.
Like the moment I kick into that mode,
like when I'm not doing it.
God,
man,
I was so cool and I was training with
this guy for a while.
And you start getting into that and to
health and like you start getting into
that place.
It's incredible and that stuff holds
less of a gravitational pull.
But man,
I guess it's some form of addiction or
is 100% of form of addiction.
It's dopamine.
There was a whole article about it
recently and one of those scientific
American,
I think,
or one of those science journals that
was,
uh,
talking about why it's so difficult for
people to quit bad habits because you,
you,
those bad habits,
they,
the trigger dopamine releases in your
mind when you remember how great it was
to eat those donuts.
Fuck it.
Let's just do it.
Let's just give it an to have that
burger and a beer.
Oh,
this is is glorious.
But the problem is in you,
you allow those pathways to exist.
If it's not,
if you don't allow it,
if the cigarettes never get in your
body,
like I don't allow cigarettes.
I'm pretty sure he gives you cancer.
I see people smoking cigarettes.
I know they get tired quicker.
I know it's terrible for you,
right?
So I don't allow it.
When I see people smoking cigarettes,
I'm like,
what?
And he allowed cigarettes into his life
and that's what you're doing,
right?
Like it's not that I couldn't get
addicted.
I think we can all get addicted.
If I started smoking cigarettes and I
realize oh there's a cognitive benefit
to smoke it on these things,
I'm just going to puff on a couple of
day.
There'll be die head smoke,
maybe a half a pack if I'm stressed.
Right.
Next thing you know I'm freaking out
because I can't get a pack of
cigarettes.
Why?
Cause I will allow this demon into my
life and I think the same exist with
processed sugar and getting off of sugar
for just a few days.
Just a few days,
which is not that difficult to thing.
You just give yourself a pattern for
five days that you have to follow.
This is all I'm allowed to eat.
This is all just do it for five days.
You get headaches,
you realize how crazy it is.
Shitty headaches.
You start losing weight,
your,
your body starts looking different.
You start getting thinner,
you start being less inflamed.
Sugar is a fucking monster.
So they said may exist in the form of
alcohol to my friend.
Oh,
I know.
That's the same goddamn thing.
Pull the pull of alcohol is the same
sugar.
Same with sugar.
It's the same pool of the bread,
the same pool of the Pasta Pasta today.
To this day,
it drives me crazy.
If you had a bowl of linguine with clams
right now,
it's like,
aw,
look at that.
Laureus just Mao health food,
just bad health.
Just glue.
I know,
man.
Laurie is glue.
Well,
it's called a watch yourself.
It's cool to watch yourself get sucked
into it and it is like,
you know the thing you're making me
realize.
It's like a,
I've never thought of myself as a
victim,
but anytime you trick yourself into
thinking this is what I do,
then you have tricked yourself into
becoming a victim.
You've decided you're a victim.
Well,
it's more importantly,
it's contrary to the entire two hours
and 20 minutes.
And you were talking about,
you're right for that moment.
Yeah.
It's a massive flaw.
You're right.
It's,
it's not a flaw.
It's just a pattern that you allow,
right.
Because you've had it in your life and
it's,
it's such a struggle
excepted.
It's existence.
You're right,
man.
You're right.
This is where the rubber hits the road,
man.
That's why I love you as my friend,
but it's like these kinds of,
uh,
these kinds of patterns.
Like I guess the next time I find myself
now,
see there I'm doing it again.
I guess when I'm eating cake or the next
time I'm putting some shitty sugar into
my math,
I just have to realize I'm threading the
necklace right now.
Like I'm the one who's like creating the
version of myself where I'm a little bit
out of shape and yes,
you know,
and just as long as you realize that
you're the one doing it,
that just throws you into such a funny
predicament though,
right?
Because when you realize like shit,
I am completely in control of who I am
as a person.
Right?
And in this situation,
I'm making the decision to sculpt a
version of myself that sucks.
Or you know,
and,
and why.
And when you instill,
like when you and your defined by this
past version of you,
right?
Like with all the knowledge
that you have right now in your head,
you're still defined by all these
failures from a decade ago.
Right?
More,
right.
They're all fucking rolling around in
your head that you have to repeat them.
This is what I do,
man.
No,
you're totally right.
Yeah.
It's still cool.
Total blind spot,
man.
You're right though.
That is a way that I talked to myself.
Everybody does it.
What I do,
man,
to find her sets fucking hilarious.
Well at the mind is so goddamn tricky
that,
yeah,
man.
That's really cool.
Here's one thing that I've gotten out of
this wacky diet that I'm on for the last
16 days or so,
17 days,
whatever it is right now,
it's something after two weeks,
right?
I'm not less happy.
Oh,
right.
I'm not,
I'm not less happy from eating shitty
food,
right?
Like my kids had cupcakes last night
after dinner.
There's a little cupcakes,
little tiny ones.
They have 10 grams of sugar.
One fucking little tiny cupcake.
That's insane.
Like how much is a big one happened
anyway,
I didn't feel bad.
I don't feel bad that I'm not getting to
eat a cupcake and I don't feel bad that
I'm not eating a bowl of pasta.
It looks amazing.
I bet it's great when it goes down.
It's not affecting my happiness,
but if I got fat,
would it affect my happiness if I looked
at myself in the mirror,
I'm like,
you fucking slaw.
What does all this shit I can't wrap
around here?
And there's all this stuff that affects
my happiness.
It affects the way I move.
It affects the way my body recovers.
It affects the way my energy levels are,
right?
The food I eat 100% affects the way my
entire day goes.
If I eat a big ass salad in the morning
with Avocados and olive oil and Balsamic
vinegarette and I eat that and I,
then I have some coconut oil or mct oil
and some coffee,
and then I have,
you know,
maybe a small,
a bowl of blueberries with some plain
yogurt and I'm eating like nothing but
healthy food.
And then I'll have like an elk steak
with some asparagus.
Dude,
I feel fucking great.
I feel great.
I've got crazy energy.
My energy levels were very high.
I'm drinking water all the time.
No juices,
no bullshit,
no sugar,
no nothing.
I am more happy.
I'm not less happy because I'm not
getting the sugar right.
It was only for a couple days.
It's a trick,
right?
It's a fucking trick.
We've all fallen into man,
right?
We look at that.
We'd go to get a Burrito and you get a
fucking soda and you're like,
Yay.
But the things that you're getting the
pleasure out of our tricks and they're
not there.
It's a temporary thing that will ruin
the rest of the enjoyment of your
experience in life.
Right?
It will sabotage it.
It'll make it less effective.
It'll make your brain work shittier when
your brain is processing a giant bowl of
pasta.
Good luck winning jeopardy,
right?
Fucking luck.
Your brain's going to be dog shit with a
bowl of spaghetti and meatballs and a
beer.
You've got a dumb fucking brain.
She got a brain.
It's like,
you know,
everything's shut her down.
Shut her down,
shut off,
functions down.
You've got critical functions,
just eh,
heartbeat.
Breathe.
Make sure you figured out how to get
home.
All the other fucking the universe
and reestablishing your existence and no
title.
Sorry.
Bowlful of Shit.
We just throw it down the hatch.
You've got to fucking process now.
I mean,
you know,
in most
religious traditions and especially most
meditative practices,
one thing you never hear people say is
she see you,
whatever you want,
or we're going to just do this thing.
You just eat whatever you want and it'll
usually,
there's like some fairly like strict
ideas of like what to eat.
Usually it involves eating very simple
foods.
You know,
just like eating lentils,
rice,
but being very simple and what you,
what you eat and eating much less than
what you eat.
Fasting.
A lot of people recommend fasting.
Fasting has a scientific reason behind
it,
and it's the same thing that I'm trying
to do with this diet.
It's establishing ketosis.
S a a state of ketosis where your body's
living off of fat.
One of the best ways to do that is
intermittent fasting right fast and
gives your body a chance to process all
the food that it has in its system and
then switch over to using fats.
This is a normal part of being a person
because being a human being for the
longest time did not mean three square
meals a day,
right?
It meant going on these journeys where
you didn't get any food for a couple of
days.
And if your body is glucose based,
and obviously I'm not a fucking
scientist and obviously there's a lot of
people that disagree with me and there's
a lot of people that disagree with Mark
Sisson and all these other people,
the Augustino,
all these different scientists and
biologists who swear by this key to
genic diet.
It is a very controversial thing.
So let me just say this right away.
I'm not a scientist,
I'm just trying it out.
But the reasoning behind it to me is
very rational and it makes sense that if
you're constantly taking carbohydrates
and you're living off these
carbohydrates as your main fuel source,
which is what you do when you eat a lot
of carbohydrates,
this is what's been established when
your body's in a state of Ketosis,
it's living off of fats,
you're burning fats,
and you could take exogenous ketones,
which is that these fucking things,
I pour them into water.
There's a bunch of different companies
that create these.
Kido Kana is one that,
uh,
my friend denny uses it.
I know a lot of athletes that are doing
this.
Kyle Kingsbury,
who is a former UFC fighter,
crazy.
He's really into it.
My friend denny proper coast,
who's a a,
one of them,
Eddie Bravo's,
a black belts.
He runs a 10th planet San Francisco,
good friend of mine.
He's in a state of Ketosis to make
meeting mostly fats,
eating oils like coconut oils,
Avocados,
things along those lines.
Healthy,
healthy grass fed meats.
What about like gluten free bread?
Is that okay?
No,
cause this is all grains.
Those are carbohydrates.
This is not,
it's not that it's bad.
What about rice?
You could exist off rice,
brown rice,
okay.
You can be fine,
but you're not listening.
All right has your carbohydrates.
If you use that as your primary food
fuel,
you're not going to be in a state of
ketosis.
It's easy for your body to process
carbohydrates like this,
but if you're in a state of Ketosis,
your body's processing fats.
When your body's processing fats,
here's where it gets really weird in
between meals.
You don't get a crash.
I don't crash like I was crashing.
If I had like breakfast.
Okay.
And if I had breakfast and it was toast
with a potatoes and rice and beans and
it's all carbs,
right,
right.
Meeting this,
this breakfast,
there's gonna come a time,
a few hours later while I'm fucking
starving,
dude,
I'm starving.
I don't get that right now.
I'm not getting that.
I can go a long time without eating.
Like I eat breakfast and then I'm good
for hours and hours and hours of
nothing.
I mean,
I might have a little snack here and
there,
but I don't absolutely need it like I
did.
Right.
I was eating a lot of carbohydrates.
Yeah,
I get it.
I'm,
I'm look,
I'm just trying this.
I might go back after 60 days and say I
like this,
but I also like to have a certain amount
of carbohydrates in my diet because it
makes it easier for me to find healthy
foods to eat because I don't think
there's anything is not,
there's not negative consequences to a
carbohydrate based diet,
but I think there are some positives to
consider about being in a state of
ketosis.
And so I'm trying it.
So that's where I'm at right now,
but,
but in the discipline,
in forcing myself to do it,
it makes me think that a lot of what we
were talking about earlier about not
having control of your impulses and your
behavior and getting,
giving into video game addiction and
giving into cell phone addiction on
social media addiction,
all these things.
I think they're all very related and
that I think that discipline,
this is a guy that I know,
his name is Jocko willink and he's a
former navy seal.
He's got a podcast now.
I talked him into it.
He's got this great book that he wrote.
I think I have it here somewhere.
It's actually,
it's actually,
it's actually out there on the coffee
table owners.
She extreme ownership.
Thank you.
Fascinating guy.
He came ownership,
he's got,
but he's got this one statement that
discipline equals freedom.
And I was like,
well,
okay,
well how do you mean?
What do you,
what do you mean by that?
And he explained it to me in very
succinct terms.
If you have the discipline to get all
the shit done,
then you can do things you enjoy and
then you're,
you're not,
you're not compromised by your lack of
discipline.
You're not trapped by your lack of
When you're emerging from a fucking 16
hour binge of playing video games,
you're stepping outside.
It's 9:00 AM and your eyes are
bloodshot.
You feel like a fucking prisoner and
your Dick is rock.
He's been beaten off the last 45
minutes.
Did you fuck your prisoner?
You're a prisoner to your indulgences.
The same thing I think can be said with
your diet.
The same thing can be said with
indulging the idea of you always being
in a state of being overweight.
The same thing can be said with a
million other things that people do that
they never follow through on.
I always wanted to be a singer.
I never had the balls to pursue it.
I always wanted to be a painter,
but I never had the time to paint after
my fucking job because I'm working over
because I just bought a new car.
But a little,
a little,
uh,
it's,
there's,
there's traps that we will set for
ourselves,
but if you,
if you give yourself a healthy trap,
you give yourself like a healthy
protocol,
a healthy directive,
a healthy pattern that you have to
follow,
you find some peace in that.
And the thing about this fucking wacky
diet is,
the thing that's most shocking to me is
that I'm not any less happy than I'd be
if I was eating ice cream or stuff and
pizza down my fat phase are letting my
book and cheeks blow,
but
I'm not,
I'm not any less happy,
I'm happy,
I'm very happy.
I'm more happy because I have energy.
So even if it's not a car bay
carbohydrate thing,
even if it's just a,
I've eliminated sugars,
even if it's,
I've just allowed myself my body to take
a break off the fucking insulin spike,
right?
Eating a giant bowl of pasta,
even if it's just that,
whatever the fuck it is,
it's working and I think they're
connected.
I think it's connected to me forcing
myself to get regular exercise.
I don't allow myself to not get
exercise.
It's not in there.
I don't allow it because I've done it
before.
I don't like it.
Right.
So I don't allow it.
And in not allowing it,
it's never an option.
So if I,
if my alarm is set and I get up and it's
what's Today,
oh,
today is death sprints on the elliptical
machine.
Well that's what I have to fucking do.
Right?
We just do it.
Cause I don't,
I can't do everything and unless I do
everything,
unless I follow all the shit that I have
on my list,
I'm not going to be able to go fuck off
and,
and enjoy a television show.
I'm not going to be,
I'm not going to appreciate those things
because I've forced myself to get the
shit done that I need to get done.
And I forced myself to follow this weird
pattern.
Discipline.
You could do the same thing.
Oh yeah,
man.
I mean I know I could do about it could.
Yeah,
it's cool.
Well it's a,
it's a beautiful idea.
I mean it really is like the,
I think there is something like very
exciting about it.
Anytime I've pulled off even the most
mild discipline in my life,
the end result is like incredible.
Have you been raving about how good you
felt once you started working out with a
trainer for a couple of months?
But I read the exact thing you were
saying.
I fucking hurt myself doing dead lifts
and then,
uh,
because of that injury I stopped working
out and then because of that I use that
as an excuse and then I started like,
I just fell off the wagon again.
You should,
you should do something that's a
practice,
that sort of thing.
No,
your,
whether it's a martial art,
which you tried a little bit in the
past,
but I think the best one for you at this
point is probably yoga because I think
yoga fits right into your sensibilities.
Yeah,
that's cool.
So instead of like having some guy who
comes over and makes you jump on a box
and skip rope,
go to a fucking yoga class,
man.
Well,
no,
this guy,
the guy I work with at Equinox,
George Chen,
the best,
he's fucking really cool mashery until
like,
there's something in that.
But I'm not going to do that forever.
I can't afford a trainer forever.
But what do you,
what do you listen more?
More crazy talk.
What?
He's going to start not being
successful.
I want to start failing at comedy.
I don't mean that.
I mean I don't want to like,
I just don't want to have a trainer
forever.
I don't want to have a trainer.
Yeah,
so this is great man.
This is an awesome therapy.
Like you're,
it's really cool now your identify like
it's cool.
You're being like very strict on the way
I'm talking like to myself.
No,
I just,
I just know you write real good,
right?
We've been friends for a long time.
It's true.
And this is this one thing where you'll
come in and come out of,
right.
It's like a trance.
When you,
when you're in a trance,
I almost forgot to grab your shoulders,
wake up.
But you'll come out of that trance guns
blazing.
Like,
dude,
I had a fucking sound and I ran four
miles.
It's the best you come out of that
training,
but then you'll slide,
you'll slow.
Why?
I like having a trainer because he
forces you to like really work hard,
like way harder than normally.
I forced myself to work out like a
trainer makes you feel like you're like
passing out from in its crate and I end
the feeling after working out hard like
that,
there's nothing like it.
I don't know anything like it better
than almost anything that I could think
of.
It's the most incredible thing,
but you have to do it regularly,
you know?
And also the Diet.
It's all diet.
For me,
my,
my real problem is just eating like shit
at night.
It's sucks.
Just eat healthy at night.
Just [inaudible] just pull yourself and
I swear you can do this.
Put yourself on a super strict diet for
20 days.
Just make it 20 days.
Just write down 20 days for 20 days.
I'm not eating any bullshit and make
them write down what you can and can't
eat or you know,
maybe you can talk to a nutritionist
that's not hard to do.
Say,
I want to do this for my podcast.
I'm going to document it for 20 days.
I'm going to eat real healthy.
Yes.
Part of the reason why I said I was
going to do it for 60 days cause I,
I wanted to say it on the air.
I wanted to say it as annoying as it
might be to hear me talk about it all
the time.
I'm saying it because I want to be
committed to it.
That's cool.
I don't want to like,
Hey,
I don't want to say I'm just eating real
clean.
That's a smart way to do it.
You know,
I forced herself,
I had a whole scheme when I started
working at this last time that I was
going to get in really good shape and
then talk about how I did it.
So I kept it a secret.
So like I was like,
man,
I was working out.
I started with Justin.
I was working so fucking hard,
man.
I really was like harder than I'd ever
done and then I just blew it and it
sucks.
It happens,
man.
Sucks.
It's a constant battle that most people
have.
It's a constant trap that most people
It's super fucking common.
It's one of the most common things that
people fall back to where it's shitty
foods.
I love the year I will take into account
what you've said.
Honestly,
man,
I'd like to continue to be super
personal.
The idea right now,
when I think to just do 20 days of like
eating healthy,
when I think about that,
I feel like this combination of like
boredom and despair,
it's like,
but you can still eat delicious food,
right?
That's where it's so confusing.
You just don't drink fruit juice.
Okay.
You get fruit juice.
You're drinking sugar water.
What an hour and even orange juice.
No,
you're not supposed to eat an orange,
right?
Don't drink that shit.
This is not normal.
We figured some stupid way to
hijack our reward systems and jolted
with sugar,
blah,
blah.
Now I've got my own Jay.
I'm drinking old.
You chicken fucking sugar.
I mean it's better than soda because
there's vitamin C in it,
but coconut water,
some of it is okay,
but if you drink too much of it,
it's probably sweet,
right?
If it's sweet,
there's some sugars in it.
You're supposed to eat the whole thing.
It's supposed to all be together.
You have an orange.
It's what?
This is a fiber in that thing.
You're supposed to,
it's all,
it's supposed to be a part of that.
When you eat an apple,
that's how supposed to get apple juice.
Supposed to get it from the fucking not
supposed to get a quarter of that shit
and throw it into your fat horse.
This reminds me,
there's a great show.
I don't know how much time we have,
but there's a,
there's a great show called from fit to
fat to fit.
Yeah,
I've heard about it that make trainers
get fat.
It's bad ass.
Um,
there it is.
Yeah.
This is really cool man.
And it's like the trainers,
when they talk about what it's like to
get fat like that,
how their personalities change.
Like they really throw themselves in the
hole and it's like,
it's amazing.
The psychological component of it.
It's really,
you should watch it on 70 pounds on
8,000 calorie a day diet.
Donna's hill,
personal trainer,
gorgeous on donuts and Mcdonald's every
day.
Man.
That is that.
As these guys are bad,
these are heroes,
man,
because they get themselves really sick
for these people and then they climb out
of the hole.
Well good for them because they are
doing it consciously in the understand
what,
what the whole purpose of this thing is
versus like someone who just,
you know,
tanks and then you have to hear about
them pulling themselves back from the
brink.
You know?
Can I am,
can I pitch these pitch picture fucking
friends?
I have to announce him dates.
I'm going to be the Denver comedy works
this weekend.
I've got a massive tour sponsored by
squarespace starting at the end of
March.
I'm going to be in Boston,
Philadelphia,
all over Canada.
It's all on my website and I'm going to
be at the spring retreat and Ron doss
spring retreat in Hawaii.
It's a meditation retreat.
I'm doing podcasts there and I hope you
will come.
Oh,
you just summon the crazy from all over
the world.
The fucking highlight hurricane crazy.
I love the crazy.
It's on my website
all the day to their full Dong controls
with Joe.
You're the best brother.
I love him.
So much fun.
Powerful.
Thank you very much.
Always.
Awesome.
All right,
Duncan trussell family hour.
Subscribe to that Shit and itunes and a,
see you tomorrow.
Yup.
Bucks.
Cool,
man.
Thanks dude.